j'ai donc le plaisir d'inviter madame
alessia lefébure directrice de l'école
et monsieur jean marc jancovici sur
scène
[Applaudissements]
mais
je sais pas si c'est parti
chers étudiants rentrent chers étudiants
chers collègues chère communauté de
l'institut agro rennes angers campus de
rennes et caen puis ce danger qui vient
d'arriver in extremis
et puis chers partenaires qui nous
regardent à distance et peut-être à
quelques représentants des écoles
voisines
llopez de rennes le mns et puis cher
tout le monde qui regarde la vidéo via
le live youtube c'est un grand plaisir
pour moi alessia lefébure des matrices
de l'institut agro rennes-angers de vous
accueillir à cette deuxième étape du
cycle de débats transformé
alors cette
ce temps que nous allons passer ensemble
avec jean marc jancovici est un temps
qui s'inscrit dans un projet qui a
beaucoup de sens pour nous dans cette
école
c'est ce n'est pas un cycle de
conférences quelconque même si nous
avons l'habitude d'avoir des grands
témoins qui viennent régulièrement tous
les ans pour nous parler de tel ou tel
sujet d'actualité c'est c'est un projet
qui qui a émergé cette année et qui est
fortement
fédérateur je dirais c'est un euphémisme
mobilisateur pour l'ensemble de nos
communautés
alors le nom qui a été trouvé qui ne
fait pas l'objet d'un consensus mais qui
au fond se rapproche le plus possible de
son sens et transformé
derrière le mot transformé il y a
l'expression d'un désir de la part de
nos étudiants et de nos étudiantes de
prendre une part peut-être plus actives
à ceux
à ce grand changement qui est en cours
qui porte le nom de transition on en
parlera un peu plus mais de façon
particulière pourquoi je dis ça parce
que nous sommes ici dans une école à
gros et donc par définition les les
jeunes qui ont décidé jeunes et moins
jeunes qui ont décidé de s'engager dans
un cursus ici sont des gens qui ont été
atteints qui sont intéressés par les
métiers du vivant
ce sont des personnes qui vont
intervenir dans les évolutions des
systèmes agricoles et alimentaires qui
sont au fond au coeur de cette
transition donc ce sont des personnes
qui ont toutes les connaissances
scientifiques et tous les outils
méthodologiques en théorie pour être une
partie prenante de cette transition
mais en fait
il se voit pas forcément comme des
acteurs du changement peut-être sur le
plan politique sur le plan économique
sur le plan du plaidoyer sur le plan de
tout ce qu'on a à faire de tout ce que
jean-marc fait entre autres et donc on a
voulu créer ce cycle il s'appelle
transformé
pour essayer de mettre ensemble tout ce
qui se fait dans cette école
de façon un peu plus transversale
autrement dit est-ce qu'on permet à un
moment donné à l'ensemble des étudiants
à l'ensemble des enseignants chercheurs
à l'ensemble des collègues veillera à
l'ensemble des parties prenantes les
alumni et caetera et bien d'avoir cette
vision transversale qui est nécessaire
pour les charges pour les changements
systémiques voilà et donc ça c'est ça
c'est le contexte on a choisi d'en faire
non pas un cycle de conférences avec des
grands témoins ce qui était une des
idées au départ un cycle de débats
et c'est là que c'est très intéressant
la proposition forte des étudiants et de
leurs enseignants et enseignantes c'est
de dire on prend prétexte de la venue de
ces grands témoins jean jouzel le mois
dernier jean-marc aujourd'hui et
d'autres suivront on prend prétexte
pardon mémoire les guillemets de leur
venue pour travailler très en amont la
problématique et préparer cette
intervention
et c'est là que je je je voudrais dire
que ce qui se produit à chaque fois
c'est la deuxième fois mais j'espère ça
va continuer c'est un vrai petit miracle
c'est à dire que il ya une mobilisation
que moi j'ai rarement vu de tout le
monde pour préparer en profondeur pour
prendre du temps sur les courts pour
prendre du temps sur le temps libre
vous les enseignants que vous ont
accompagné alors aujourd'hui on m'a dit
qu'on vous a pas encadré quand vous
qu'on a peut-être facilité en détendant
l'ambiance les vos enseignants se sont
décrits dans ce rôle de facilitateur
mais peu importe il ya quelque chose de
très fédérateur qui se produit et donc
pour ça c'est la seule chose que je peux
dire ce qu'on m'a dit de ne pas
présenter jean marc jancovici
donc je me retiens très très fort de le
faire qu'est ce que ça sera le rôle de
nos étudiants de nos étudiantes mais ce
que je vais dire c'est que grâce à lui
et grâce à tous ceux qui viendront ceux
et celles qui viendront après il se
produit quelque chose de très fort dans
cette école qui me semble remarquable et
qui me semble enfin d'entonner tous et
toutes très très fier et j'espère que ça
aura de l'impact d'ici quelques années
donc je termine le sait que ces quelques
mots dans ce qui m'a permis de dire
aujourd'hui pour remercier tout le monde
de la participation donc les enseignants
les étudiants et tous les personnels les
équipes techniques nous permettent aussi
de réaliser le live puisqu'on a des
locaux qui nous permettent pas de faire
face à la grand afflux de demandes de
participation
et puis et puis pour vous dire
effectivement que c'est un rendez-vous
qu'on a envie de pérenniser de
poursuivre delà du semestre en fin de
semestre de poursuivre le semestre
suivant l'année prochaine et cetera de
continuer et peut-être sous des formes
réinventer donc voilà bon soyez soyez
bon on donnait une bonne image de
l'école et puis bonne continuation à
tout le monde et je passe la parole à
à maxence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci madame lefébure bonjour à tout le
monde que vous soyez est un hymne à
grains ou sur notre live youtube à
rennes angers montpellier ou dijon
bonjour à monsieur jean marc jancovici
nous sommes très heureux de vous
accueillir ici
voici raphaël line et moi-même maxence
nous sommes tous trois étudiants en
filière agronomie et seront les
animateurs du jour
mais tout de suite je vais laisser la
place à aurait lui aussi en agronomie
qui va faire votre présentation à son
rythme bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
bonjour jean marc jancovici bienvenue à
l'institut agréé des engins c'est donc
maintenant au tour des étudiants de vous
présenter et de vous dire que nous
sommes très heureux de vous accueillir
parmi nous aujourd'hui on parle le
conférencier vulgarisateur de gourou
voire même de meilleur expert mondial du
carbone de politique ni essien ou prend
parler des dénominations ne manquent pas
en même temps vous avez de nombreuses
corde à votre arc tout commence le 13
février 1962 ensuite vous sortez diplômé
de polytechnique en 84 et de télécom
paris en 86 vous commencé à vous
intéresser au réchauffement climatique
dans le courant des années 90 c'est le
début d'une longue histoire d'amour en
effet suite à cela vous développer au
sein de l'ademe la technique de calcul
du bilan carbone entre 2000 et 2004 en
2007 vous démarrez je vous cite
l'activité qui aujourd'hui est destiné à
remplir votre frigidaire
c'est à dire la création du cabinet
carbone 4 avec alain grandjean
l'objectif de ce cabinet et la
transformation des entreprises vers la
décarbonation et l'adaptation aux
changements climatiques vous devenez
ensuite enseigné en huile en 2008 et
vous êtes fondateur et président du chip
project en 2002 puis 2010 the chief
project est un film take qui oeuvre en
faveur d'une économie libéré de la
contrainte carbone qui d'ailleurs a
sorti le plan de transformation de
l'économie française ptf ce janvier 2022
et alors qu'en parallèle de la campagne
présidentielle qui bat son plein tout
comme les candidats en meeting vous
enchaînez les conférences visant entre
autres à présenter son plan de
transformation
mais très récemment aussi vous avez avec
christophe blain sorti votre bande
dessinée à succès le monde sans fin
d'année tellement à s'user qui a été
très difficile pour nous se la procurer
cela vous a vu au centre de l'attention
médiatique en même temps vous avez mis
en lumière que vous possédiez l'armure
d'iron man est telle que les stars vous
est maintenant sous le feu des
projecteurs j'espère que vous retrouvez
dans cette présentation de votre
parcours et tout ceci nous amène au
point culminant
votre brillante carrière c'est à dire
répond aux questions de l'institut al
graw réel danger merci à vous bonne
conférence à tous
merci beaucoup pour cette présentation
aurel avant de commencer le débat je
vais laisser monsieur jancovici nous
présenter le plan de transformation de
l'économie française réalisée par lui et
son équipe au sein du chiffre project
merci alors d'abord je félicite aurel
non seulement pour sa coiffure de
d'artagnan mais aussi parce que très
réussie
et très en phase avec le caractère
historique des lieux
parce que vous avez réussi à échapper au
triple écueil de ma page wikipédia je
vous rappelle que les pages wikipédia on
peut ne pas en écrire une ligne quand on
aime quand on en est l'objet ce qui est
mon cas
et aux batailles médiatiques dans
lesquelles chacun donne son avis avec de
part et d'autre en général quelques
exagérations
voilà donc
la le plan de transformation de
l'économie française donc pour répondre
à la question est un enfant qui dans la
conception a démarré au moment du
premier confinement du candidat donc
vous avez cette période qui était si
sympathique pour vous étudiants on vous
a dit les bars vous avez oublié
vous avez oublier les soirées vous avez
de chez vous derrière un écran
d'ordinateur et suit des cours
alors o'shea project quand le premier
confinement duo qu'ovide est arrivé on
s'est fait la réflexion suivante qui
était qu' à l'évidence l'économie allait
ralentir et très très vite on s'est dit
c'est dommage ça serait l'occasion savez
quand une voiture ralentissait d'accès
plus facile de la faire changer
brusquement de direction donc ça serait
l'occasion éventuellement de faire
repartir l'économie d'une autre manière
sauf que tient en fait on se rend compte
qu'on n'a pas le mode d'emploi pour la
faire repartir d'une manière très
différente et d'oncologie project il est
né l'idée à ce moment là
de faire quelque chose qui serait le
mode d'emploi de comment est ce que on
oriente l'économie d'une manière qui est
assez différente si l'occasion s'en
présente et donc c'est très exactement
ça qui est le cadre du plan de
transformation de l'économie française
c'est si on veut vraiment être sérieux
avec ce qu'on appelle l'accord de paris
c'est-à-dire avec le fait de faire
baisser les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre à la bonne vitesse pour rester
sous les fameux deux degrés de
réchauffement qui dans une école
d'agronomie devrait être un truc auquel
vous êtes particulièrement sensible
parce que je signale que à deux degrés
par exemple y aura plus beaucoup
d'épicés à et de mettre en france que
les soldes vont perdre 20% d'humilité
sur tout le pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen france comprise là vous
êtes aussi vous avez probablement vu
dans l'actualité qu'on s'apprête à se
prendre quelques gelées alors qu'une
bonne partie de la végétation à des
bourrées et donc il va y avoir de gros
dégâts dans les cultures fruitières et
la vigne bis repetita par rapport à
l'année dernière où c'était déjà le cas
et ça vient se rajouter un hiver
extrêmement fins extrêmement un hiver
raisonnablement sec et qui fait que l'on
commence déjà à voir des sécheresses
agricole dans une partie du pays
notamment dans le sud voilà donc là les
deux degrés je pense que dans votre
école ça devrait vous parle et ça
devrait être quelque chose auquel vous
êtes vraiment sensible et plein d'autres
trucs je vais vous dire sans vous cirer
les pompes c'est que l'agriculture ça a
beau être deux pour cent du pib si on
mange pas les 98 % restants pose un tout
petit problème de réalisation donc le
plan de transformation de l'économie
française c'est comment est ce qu'on
fait pour mettre l'économie encore une
fois en phase avec cette baisse des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre est là
aussi pour vous donner un chiffre que
vous devriez probablement avoir en tête
si comme on va vous inviter à le faire
vous avez regardé une intervention en
ligne vend toujours la même chose avant
de venir dans cette salle si on veut
baisser les émissions planétaires à la
bonne vitesse pour rester sous les deux
degrés le chiffre qu'il faut avoir en
tête c'est 5% ça va nous renvoyer aussi
aux coville il faut que les émissions
planétaires baisse de 5% par an 5 %
c'est la paix ce qu'on a eu en 2020 à
cause du ralentissement économique dû au
vide donc il faudrait avoir ce genre de
baisse tous les ans donc 5 % 2 5% de
plus un pas à 5 % sur 5 5% de plus tous
les ans si on veut que le réchauffement
planétaire soit limitée à moins de 2
degrés 2° - donc vous voyez que c'est
pas une mince affaire parce que le
confident par une fois est associé à des
souvenirs extrêmement plaisant de votre
côté implique leur échelle soit puis
d'erasmus enfin bon bref tout un pack
très sympa donc là là
ce plan il est né à ce moment là donc la
question qu'on s'est posée c'est si on
veut faire ce genre de choses il faut
qu'on renverse l'ordre de priorité par
rapport à ce qu'on a l'habitude de faire
qu'est ce qu'on a l'habitude de faire
quand on est dans l'organisation de la
vie en commun de la vie collective on a
l'habitude de se mettre sous un critère
premier qui s'appelle l'argent donc
votre directrice qui vient de s'exprimer
elle a un cadre de réflexion dans lequel
on lui dit un budget et puis toute idée
brillante que tu pourrais avoir si elle
n'est pas compatible avec ton budget
oublie l'idée brillante voilà c'est
comme ça nous on s'est dit on va pas se
mettre dans ce système de raisonnement
là on va mettre l'argent en deuxième
plan pas en premier donc la façon dont
on a résonné dans le plan de
transformation de l'économie française
c'est comment est ce qu on réoriente nos
activités productives vu sous l'angle
physique que les activités productives
cd ans et des flux physiques et on prend
des ressources on les transforme on
prend des choses on les déplace et c'est
tout ça c'est physique et donc comment
est ce que on réorganise les flux
physiques de notre système productif
pour que les émissions baisse sous
double contrainte qui est une contrainte
de ressources donc la planète est finie
comme vous le savez elle fait
désespérément treize mille kilomètres de
diamètre et pas plus alors c'est
suffisamment vaste pour faire des grands
voyages pendant les erasmus mais
suffisamment limité pour que à 8
milliards d'individus de temps en temps
soit un peu gêné quand il s'agit d'avoir
suffisamment de ressources pour tout le
monde donc on sait lit sous contraintes
de ressources et ont sévi sous
contrainte de ce que je pourrais
qualifier d'exutoire c'est-à-dire
d'environnement et on a regardé comment
on pouvait s'organiser pour ne pas
émettre
plus que les émissions qui sont
autorisés pour se limiter sous 2 degrés
et une deuxième limite qu'on s'est
imposé dans cet exercice c'est une
limite en compétences manifestement il
faut quelques années pour former un
ingénieur agronome post bac sinon vous
viendriez dans cet établissement une
semaine et pas 5 ans donc acquérir des
compétences c'est quelque chose qui
demande du temps et le temps est de
nouveau une grandeur physique donc on a
dans cette approche
regardez sous double contrainte ou sous
triple contrainte de ressources des
missions et de temps c'est à dire de
compétences comment est-ce qu'on pouvait
réorganiser le système et on s'est dit
on parlera pas d'argent dans un premier
temps ce que je vous dis vous battre un
peu ésotérique je vous donne un exemple
en ce qui concerne les déplacements qui
dans notre pays représente un petit
tiers des émissions directes vous savez
un petit tiers des émissions en direct
du pays c'est le co2 qui sort des
moteurs où nous arrivons encore avec de
l'essence et du gasoil bien qu'il soit
deux euros le litre et bien si on veut
que y ait moins d'émissions qui viennent
du système de transport on va commencer
par résonner physique c'est à dire on va
commencer par regarder la part des
déplacements qu'on peut basculer sur de
la marche sur du vélo sur du vélo
électrique sur du transport en commun
bus train pas trop à lyon s'il vous
plaît et sur des voitures qui sont moins
nombreuses et qui avec moi alors moins
dangereuse ça veut dire les faire plus
petit et qui émettent moins ça veut dire
diminuer leur taille tant qu'elle reste
au pétrole et si l'on est passé à
l'électricité avec de l'électricité
décarbonés et bien quand on regarde la
façon dont ce système doit se déformer
ça veut dire qu'on va avoir besoin de
moins de gens pour fabriquer des
voitures qu'on aura moins de voitures on
aura besoin de plus de moins de gens
pour faire voler des avions parce que
dans notre monde on fait voler moins
d'avions on a plus de gens pour faire
avancer des trains et des bus et on a
besoin aussi de plus de gens pour
fabriquer des vélos électriques
ou pas électrique du reste les ventres
et les entretenir eh bien on a pas on ne
s'est pas posé la question de savoir si
comme une voiture aux 20000 euros un
vélo de ville quand même on aurait de
quoi payer les gens pas non c'est pas ça
qu'on a regardé on a dit voilà si on
veut que les émissions baisse à la bonne
vitesse il faut des formes et le système
de transport de cette manière ça veut
dire que les gens dont on a besoin pour
que ça fonctionne ils doivent être là
hélas hélas savoir faire ça ceci et cela
est uniquement derrière on se mettra un
jour éventuellement à parler d'argent
mais dans un premier temps on a juste
regarder comment ça se déformer dans le
domaine agricole c'est exactement la
même chose qu'on a regardé vous le savez
probablement l'agriculture est à
l'origine d'à peu près 20% des émissions
dans ce pays et c'est à peu près la même
chose dans le monde ce à quoi il faut
rajouter 10 % déforestation dans le
monde donc en fait si vous regardez
l'empreinte carbone du système
alimentaire mondial 20% d'émissions
directes 10 % déforestation et ajoutez
moi à 5% pour les émissions
industrielles associés l'agroalimentaire
la fabrication des emballages rajouter
mois également un ou deux pour cent pour
les transports associés la flotte
mondiale de camions ces 4 % par exemple
des émissions mondiales et en france au
moins un camion sur trois transporte un
truc qui se mange voilà donc on vous
fait ma petite cuisine là et donc on a à
peu près un tiers des émissions liées à
l'alimentation alors comme la première
option consiste en avoir moins de
bouches à nourrir n'est pas une option
qu'on peut activer à l'échelle de la
semaine enfin en tout cas pas dans un
contexte très sympathique dans le
contexte donc lock-up oui mais dans un
contexte très sympathique non eh bien on
a
essentiellement regarder comment est-ce
qu'on pouvait modifier les régimes
alimentaires et les votes de production
pour que les émissions baisse à la bonne
vitesse là aussi c'est à dire de l'ordre
de 5% par an et donc on se rend compte
par exemple il faut mettre plus de
valeur à cette pré mauvaise nouvelle
pour les genres dans la salle qui sont
qui se destinent à l'industrie
agroalimentaire faut - d'industries
agroalimentaires plus de transformation
sur l'exploitation du coup ça permet de
raccourcir les chaînes logistiques
il faut également diversifier les
bassins de production parce
qu'aujourd'hui la spécialisation des
bassins de production engendre du
transport aval de manière massive et il
faut diminuer la part des produits
animaux dans la diète alors on n'est pas
du tout pour supprimer la blanquette de
veau mais beaucoup moins souvent donc
voilà c'est ça le csah l'organisation
générale et ça veut dire aussi donc là
vous allez vous dire il est gentil rêve
en couleurs remettre 500 mille personnes
dans l'agriculture alors quand on sait
l'évolution des effectifs dans ce métier
là depuis maintenant quelques décennies
alors oui certes mais à l'époque où il
n'y avait pas de tracteur et pas de
phytosanitaires s'était pas
aujourd'hui six cent mille personnes
qu'on avait dans l'agriculture c'est les
deux tiers de la population active donc
le fait d'avoir un
système agricole
qui va devenir plus résilient avec des
chaînes logistiques plus courtes et des
productions localement plus diversifiée
parce que c'est ça qui rapproche la
production de la consommation ça
nécessite factuellement d'y mettre plus
de monde et à ce moment là pas de
question devient comment est ce qu'on
donne envie aux gens d'y aller et
effectivement un jour il faudra qu'on
parle voilà la philosophie globale
encore une fois du plan de
transformation de l'économie française
c'est ça c'est je regarde physiquement
comment je dois organiser les choses
pour répondre à près de physique qui est
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre il
ya un autre volet qui est traitée de
fait du coup dans ce plan c'est la
question du gaz et du pétrole russes
vous avez bien vu en ce moment que on a
un tout petit sujet pour dire à poutine
qu'il a une sale tête qui est que on
dépend vitalement enfin de manière
vitale de la part dont des importations
de combustibles fossiles en provenance
de russie pour ceux d'entre vous qui
n'ont pas les chiffres en tête l'union
européenne importe 95 % du pétrole
qu'elle consomme si je prends l'europe
au sens large en y rajoutant la norvège
et la grande-bretagne qui ne sont plus
dans l'union mais qui sont les deux
producteurs principaux d'hydrocarbures
que nous avons en europe ces 75 % du
pétrole qui est importé et un tiers des
importations vient de russie et comme
dans l'union européenne stricto sensu en
importe tout un tiers du pétrole
européen vient de russie donc la pompe à
essence là devant laquelle on est passé
tout à l'heure je suis en voyage en
voiture c'est très mal je vous dirai pas
qui était mon conducteur
à deux euros le litre et mariana matière
qui vient de russie
le gars à ce que nous utilisions dans
l'union européenne y en a 40 % qui
viendra aussi et enfin même le charbon
que nous utilisons dans l'union
européenne il y en a 25 % qui vient de
russie puisque l'union européenne
importe la moitié du charbon qu'elle
utilise ce que les mines de charbon en
europe sont en voie d'épuisement depuis
des décennies on a commencé à taper dans
notre charbon il ya deux siècles donc la
révolution industrielle s'était vieux
pour la petite histoire le pic de
production du charbon en grande bretagne
c'est 1914 ça date un peu
et donc la moitié du charbon européens
et apporté la moitié des importations
viennent de russie donc monsieur poutine
soutient gentiment parler génitoires si
je puis me permettre
et c'est pour ça que quand les européens
font la grosse voix en disant heureux on
voit à quoi non rien du tout quoi à
court terme c'est la possibilité le
seuil de douleur de se passer des
hydrocarbures russes est beaucoup trop
élevé pour que les dirigeants
démocratiquement élu et surtout voulant
démocratiquement se faire réélire dans
pas longtemps
d'europe prennent le risque de mettre un
embargo demain matin sur les
hydrocarbures provenant de russie donc
on va continuer à financer l'effort de
guerre russe tout simplement parce que
notre société est beaucoup trop
dépendantes des combustibles fossiles
aujourd'hui alors elle est dépendante
aujourd'hui elle le sera demain mais
elle le sera de moins en moins au sens
où ou indépendamment du fait que ça fait
un changement climatique les
hydrocarbures sont par ailleurs
épuisable dans cette enceinte vous savez
probablement ou en tout cas vous devriez
savoir que le pétrole le gaz et le
charbon sont des restes fossilisés de
vie ancienne
le charbon c'est des restes de fougères
qui ont poussé aux affaires du charbon
c'est à dire le carbonifère le pétrole
et le gaz c'est des restes de micro
algues et de plancton qui ont vécu dans
l'océan n'importe quand entre il ya
quelques millions d'années il ya
quelques centaines de millions d'années
tout ça a été enfoui avec des
cisaillements des sédiments minéraux par
la tectonique des plaques gentiment cuit
par la géothermie et ça vous fait du
pétrole et du gaz à l'arrivée donc ces
combustibles étant épuisables et bien on
a une commande hier on a on a une
obligation qui nous est imposée par la
finitude de ces ressources qui est
qu'avec le temps il arrivera un moment
où nous devons toute façon qu'on se fait
de moins en moins et ce temps est déjà
arrivé en europe l'europe est déjà en
décrue subit en ce qui concerne ses
approvisionnements en combustible
fossile donc même si on veut pas on va
devoir en conserver de moins en moins
donc il ya un double sujet dont convient
à tout le sujet à la fois
environnementale et de résilience c'est
la capacité à opérer dans un monde où on
va être progressivement priver d'une
ressource à modifier les systèmes qui
nous entourent dont le système agricole
ou aujourd'hui nous avons remplacé en
deux siècles des dizaines de millions
d'agriculteurs par des tracteurs des
usines d'engrais de phytosanitaires et
des camions voilà c'est par ça qu'on a
remplacé la population agricole
par des machines
ces machines on va en avoir de moins en
moins et donc par la force des choses et
donc il va falloir repenser le système
avec moins de machines donc loupé tfc ça
il ya un volet emploi qui nous a
énormément intéressé au sein du plan de
transformation de l'économie française
alors pour plusieurs raisons la première
c'est qu'au sein du shit project quand
on a commencé à réfléchir à cette
affaire on s'est rendu compte que ce qui
faisait peur aux gens quand on leur
prononcer le mot décroissance
c'était encore plus la question de
l'emploi que la question de leur propre
consommation
on s'est rendu compte que avant même que
les gens soient tétanisés à l'idée
d'habiter dans un logement un peu plus
petits ou de s'acheter moins souvent une
paire de baskets il y avait la question
c'est tellement associé dans l'esprit
des gens
croissance et fin du chômage qu'en fait
quand on leur prononce décroissance les
gens en pensent chômage donc le premier
truc qu'il est tétanisé c'est de se dire
mais dans ce monde là qu'est ce que je
fais qu'est-ce que oui oui oui mon
boulot et aussi du coup comment je fais
bouillir la marmite donc là aussi ce
sujet du pouvoir échapper ou est-ce que
je bosse donc on a absolument tenu dans
le dans le pdf a commencé à regarder le
volet emploi de très près alors ce volet
emploi on l'a traitée de manière
partielle aujourd'hui parce qu'on
n'avait pas les moyens de le traiter de
manière globale ça aurait été quoi de le
traiter de manière globale ça aurait été
non seulement de regarder les
déplacements d'emploi d'un secteur à un
autre mais par ailleurs de regarder au
sein d'un même secteur par exemple
l'enseignement les déplacements à
l'intérieur du secteur dans un monde
dans lequel on va devoir
décarbonés l'économie il ya un certain
nombre de compétences nouvelles dont on
a va avoir besoin celle là il faut les
enseigner il ya un certain nombre de
métiers qu'on a aujourd'hui qui seront
pas nécessairement
utile en tant qu'entité identique et là
ça veut dire que les enseignants qui
sont associés à ces formations là on en
aura besoin de moins or vous transformez
pas en une semaine un enseignant en
anglais en enseignant en biologie je ne
crois pas en tout cas donc il ya des
donc ça on n'a pas regardé donc les
déplacements au sein même d'un secteur
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a pas
regardé on n'avait pas là on n'avait pas
le temps et les ressources pour regarder
ça de manière fine par contre ce qu'on a
regardé si les déplacements d'emploi
entre secteurs par exemple combien
d'emplois en plus dans l'agriculture
combien en moins dans la construction
automobile convient en moins dans la
construction parce que c'est moins dans
la construction aussi je vais vous lire
pas longtemps pourquoi
combien en plus dans le système dé l'eau
etc c'est ça qu'on a fait encore une
fois sur bath plan physique donc on a
regardé quatre secteurs on a regardé
l'industrie on a regardé l'agriculture
on a regardé les transports et ailleurs
des systèmes énergétiques c4 secteur
dans lequel on a regardé la les besoins
en emploi ou les destructions d'emploi
mais il resterait à regarder plein
d'autres choses dans les services par
exemple aujourd'hui on n'est pas capable
on n'a pas mené l'investigation qui
permet de savoir si dans un monde qui se
déclarent bonne on a besoin de plus ou
de moins de vendeurs par exemple on n'a
pas regardé ça il faudrait il faut une
fois qu'on finisse par faire le boulot
le point intéressant c'est que quand on
est allé voir les organisations
syndicales de salariés en leur disant
regardez ce qu'on a fait qu'est ce que
vous en pensez on a eu club allemand a
beau d'accueil alors même qu'on venait
leur annoncer que dans certains secteurs
on voyait des destructions d'emplois
très claire de façon significative et on
sait pas du tout fait jeter des tomates
pourries on a trouvé en face de nous des
gens qui étaient intéressés à discuter
sur la base du travail qu'on avait faits
qui était encore une fois une espèce de
travail dans lequel on se raconte pas
d'histoires sur le fait qu' on va tous
préservés partout et tout le temps
puisque c'est probablement pas comme ça
que les choses vont se passer
voilà voilà à grands traits l'histoire
de ce plan de transformation et je vais
finir juste par un parent dont vous avez
compris que son acte de conception
c'était pendant le confinement un bébé
confinement son acte de naissance c'est
à dire à quel moment est-ce que ce plan
pourrait effectivement être mis en
oeuvre voilà j'ai envie de vous dire
c'est à la prochaine grosse crise
c'est suffisamment disruptif de mettre
en oeuvre une vision de cette nature
pour que ça n'ait aucune chance de se
faire dans un monde qui évolue de
manière continue donc nous ne croyons
pas une seule seconde que c'est un plan
dont on pourrait s'emparer à l'occasion
d'un événement continue et même s'il
faut aller voter un événement continue
c'est une élection présidentielle donc
c'est un événement continue serra il ya
un président avant un ou une présidente
après ou pas une grosse différence un
événement discontinue c'est par exemple
la guerre en ukraine un événement
discontinue c'est par exemple
confinement les locaux vides un
événement discontinue ça serait par
exemple un défaut de paiement sur la
dette italienne ou espagnole ou les deux
à la fois un événement discontinue ça
serait un prochain printemps arabe avec
5 millions de réfugiés cette fois ci
voilà donc il faut il faudra attendre un
événement discontinue pour que
l'électrochoc soit suffisant pour que
les gens se disent faut pas qu'on
continue à résonner comme aujourd'hui il
faut combler un autre raisonnement et à
ce moment là évidemment on n'aura pas le
temps de faire enfin à ce moment là on
sort les plans qui ont déjà été pensé
pour ce genre de circonstances al avance
et je vais le dire autrement c'est pas
au moment de l' incendie qu'on fait le
plan d'évacuation en cas d'incendié
voilà donc nous on a fait le plan
d'évacuation en cas d'incendié c'est un
peu ça qu'on a fait maintenant faut
attendre incendie si je peux continuer
ce parallèle donc il va falloir attendre
un événement discontinuer et dans
l'intervalle ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
essaye d'expliquer la manière dont on a
procédé on essaye d'expliquer à quelle
conclusion en est arrivé et on essaye de
rallier un nombre croissant de gens à un
concept important qui est en filigrane
dans cet ouvrage qui s'appelle la
planification et la planification c'est
pas le régime communiste la
planification ça veut dire qu'on
commence à raisonner sur des échelles de
temps qui vont au delà des quelques
années que nous sommes habitués à avoir
c'est ça c'est ça que c'est ça que ça
veut dire
voilà en quelques en quelques mots une
présentation du plan de transformation
de l'économie française mais je sais
aussi c'est un travail collectif ça je
précise quand même ces intras donc on va
on a mis mon nom sur la page de
couverture là parce que les lits des
éditeurs aiment pas du tout avoir des
ouvrages anonyme sans nom mais c'est un
travail collectif donc ça a été fait par
15 allez on va dire 25
chefs de projets responsables de projets
etc ça a été fait par quelques centaine
de contributeurs qui ont travaillé avec
ces gens là et ça a été relu et critique
et amendé et c'est par des milliers de
contributeurs donc c'est vraiment un
travail collectif et je pense là tout
tout amplement des chevilles assumer que
on a probablement
mis au service de cette réflexion la
plus grande quantité d'individus qu'on
n'ait jamais mis au service de cette
réflexion dans ce pays
merci beaucoup
vous avez sûrement déjà beaucoup de
questions après cette présentation mais
avant de commencer cet échange on va
vous présenter du mieux qu'on peut
l'après midi après un échange avec
monsieur jancovici nous avons décidé de
mettre en place ici à l'institut agréé
danger un format un peu différent de ses
conférences habituelles donc pour cela
on a mobilisé tous les étudiants de
l'institut et on a créé des groupes de
travaux et peu importe leurs filières
bien sûr et ses goûts de travaux a été
chapeautée par des
enseignants-chercheurs volontaire avec
qui on a visionné des conférences
réalisées au préalable
ce jancovici comme celle à polytechnique
où seul dans la chambre d'agriculture de
rodez par exemple et
c'est le sait louis l'ont pas filmée le
support de toute la conférence c'est
bien vrai
et à la suite de ces conférences on a
réalisé des moments de débats entre les
étudiants pour qu'ils et elles puissent
exprimer leur ressenti et poser leurs
questions sur ce qu'il venait de voir et
de tous ces moments des changes on en a
sorti une profusion de questions assez
colossal et toute l'équipe du projet
réfléchi à améliorer et pressé ces
questions pour au final un sélectionné
un certain nombre qui vont vous être
posée aujourd'hui nos espoirs également
que nos collègues de dijon et
montpellier qui n'ont pas pu participer
à cette préface puisse participer au
moment des échanges libres et je tiens
encore une fois remercier tous les
étudiants personnels et enseignants qui
ont participé à l'émergence de ce projet
la parole est à toi raphaël donc dans la
suite de la conférence comme l'a dit
maxence nous ont posé des questions à
monsieur jancovici donc nous avons
décidé de les ranger en plusieurs
thématiques il me semble que vous les
avez tout introduite sans le faire
exprès dans votre présentation et donc
nous avons choisi parce qu'on pense
qu'elle recouvre un panel de secteurs
qui permettront d'apprécier au mieux les
méthodes qu'on peut mettre en place pour
décarbonés l'économie française est de
plus on a choisi de préciser certaines
questions sur les programmes des
candidats à la présidentielle et sur ce
qu'ils veulent faire
plus exactement pour dakar modèle
économique donc il y aura une question
sur les programmes dans chaque
thématique elles ont été pensés par un
groupe spécifique qui a travaillé à côté
sur ce sujet et il ya certains étudiants
qui de ce groupe qui l'opposeront ces
questions
alors bien sûr vous pourrez poser vos
questions tout au long de les changes et
on prendra une question pour conclure
chaque thématique cette question devrait
être courte car monsieur jancovici a
pour défi d'y répondre en une minute
seulement
c'est un défi à la fin des changes il y
aura aussi un temps de questions libres
qui sera sûrement trop court pour vous
offrir tous la parole et on s'en excuse
d'avancé mais comment poser vos
questions pour les gens qui ont la
chance d'être ici en maths à grains il
ya des passeurs de micros dans la salle
donc vous pouvez lever la main et poser
vos questions directement pour ceux qui
nous suivent soit dans des amphis
différent ici à rennes ou angers ou
montpellier ou bien sur le live youtube
vous pouvez poser vos questions via le
groupe l'ap dont le qr code s'affiche
derrière moi ou bien dans la description
de la vidéo
de vos questions seront lus trier tout
au long de la conférence donc vous
pouvez en pause et même si elles ne
correspondent pas forcément à la
thématique abordée en cours mais avant
de commencer le débat on a une petite
question surprise de notre premier
invité monsieur jean jouzel
donc grand crime est climatologue et
membre ancien membre du giec qui vous a
adressé une question avant de nous
quitter
bonjour jean marc donc si tu étais en
responsabilité au niveau du gouvernement
et ce n'est pas impossible que ce soit
le cas dans quelques semaines qu'elle
ferait des trois premières décisions
j'avais beaucoup décevoir je vais
beaucoup décevoir ge ans d la
probabilité est un faux je vais dire
jamais mais alors c'est vraiment pas du
tout dans mes intentions d'être dans le
prochain gouvernement
c'est vraiment pas du tout dans mes
intentions pour une raison très simple
c'est que le sujet énergie climat est un
sujet qui a tellement irrigué structurer
notre société que ce n'est pas un poète
de billy star break de président et je
suis absolument certain de ne pas être
en fauteuil élyséen
pour l'excellent trio je suis pas
candidat donc
voilà donc c'est pas un preuve des
ministres c'est vraiment un problème de
serre prague le président parce que
c'est un prêt de projet de société dont
condé on délègue pas un projet de
société un ministre quel qu'il soit
qu'est-ce que alors mais je vais quand
même pour le fun comme diraient les
canadiens
c'est quoi mes trois premières mesures
alors en fait j'en aurais pour le mans
beaucoup plus de 3 une
plaisanterie que je fais parfois
c'est
si vous arrivez
chez un chirurgien à l'hôpital et que
vous avez 10 organes vitaux qui vont pas
bien si on demande aux joueurs à l'essai
quoi les deux premiers que tu va réparer
il va tous les réparer si l'on s'attache
pas à quoi bon donc dans un plan il n'y
a pas trois premières mesures tout est
important sinon réfléchirai pas un plan
d'ensemble
alors une fois que j'ai répondu par
cette pirouette nous sommes en train au
sein de duchy project d'essayer de
mettre en place j'espère qu'on va y
arriver donc j'espère que je suis pas en
train de faire une promesse de gascon
mais quelque chose qui s'appelle le
programme des cent jours vous avez que
en général quand un ou une nouvelle
présidente e est élu il ya ce qu'on
appelle un état de grâce qui est un état
pendant lequel on emmerde pas trop et en
gros il fait à peu près ils ou elles
fiables parce qu'il veut
et on est en train d'essayer de concocté
tout un tas de mesures qui peuvent être
mises en place de façon très très rapide
à partir du moment où le nouveau
locataire ou la nouvelle locataire de
l'elysée est en phase avec ce que nous
proposons c'est à dire pense vraiment
que de s'occuper de ces sujets c'est
très important alors là dedans vous
allez trouver des choses comme par
exemple il n'y a plus une loi qui est
votée sans une étude d'impact sérieuses
sur la question
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ou
dépendance à l'énergie vous allez vous
pourriez trouver par exemple dès demain
matin il ya des circulaires qui partent
à tous les directeurs d'administration
et tous les ministres en leur disant les
bâtiments qui dépend de toi tu as très
exactement dix ans pour les décarbonés
et tu as un mois pour me proposer en
retour en feuille de route pour le faire
effectivement voilà
donc par exemple madame lefébure recevra
une lettre émanant d'une lettre émanant
d'une lettre en dix ans les émissions
directes la du campus à la fin du mandat
doivent être divisées par 2 ou avoir
perdu 30%
au travail voilà c'est pas une option
quoi ça fait partie de votre feuille de
route donc voilà des voix la démesure
que qui ça peut arriver par décret ça
peut arriver par circulaire ça peut
arriver par samuel et ça peut aller très
vite ce genre de choses voilà donc il ya
un certain nombre de mesures auxquelles
on est en train de réfléchir et donc ça
sera pas trois
mais ça sera
et ça sera pas moi comme faisant partie
du gouvernement et parce qu'en plus la
question de jean ce donc je serai
ministre des affaires étrangères premier
ministre ministre de la santé ministre
de l'agriculture paix à l'actuel ou
ministre des transports je ne serai pas
les trois premières mesures identiques 1
voilà met donc la réponse qu'on la
réponse qu'on va essayer de faire c'est
un ensemble de choses en disant
chiche t'es sérieux ou chiche
truc qu'il faut si tu fais pas ça c'est
que ce n'est pas sérieux
très bien merci donc on va pouvoir
passer à la première thématique qui est
de l'agriculture à l'alimentation
est donc
l'agriculture et l'alimentation revienne
au centre des attentions avec la guerre
en ukraine puisque l'enjeu de sécurité
alimentaire est revenu au premier plan
est donc là on tendait à les lire turque
tôt écologie c'était années il ya eu un
retournement et une agriculture très
productiviste pour nourrir la polémique
population a été mise en avant et on est
également dans un contexte de
réchauffement climatique ou les
rendements agricoles
tendent plutôt à diminuer et c'est déjà
le cas dans beaucoup de pays et de plus
l'agriculture était un aussi un secteur
émetteur de gaz à effet de serre pardon
à cause des ruminants des engrais
chimiques mais également des machines
donc les machines on à la mécanisation
auchan et les machines dans les procédés
industriels pour l'agroalimentaire et
pour faire marcher tout ça il ya besoin
d'énergie fossile aujourd'hui enfin
plutôt aujourd'hui et ce sont des
énergies fossiles et donc j'en viens à
la première question qui est lié à ce
thème avec
l'abandon progressif des énergies
fossiles pensez vous que nous garderons
un modèle aussi mécanisée que l'on a
aujourd'hui au cou novo raison
reviendront vers une agriculture plus
tôt manuel et avec le changement
climatique et l'augmentation
démographique comment sera-t-il possible
de maintenir la sécurité alimentaire
globale
de questions très distinctes
si on essaye de pas faire d'angélisme
compte tenu aujourd'hui de la taille de
la population agricole
c'est évident que de se dire qu'on va se
priver d'auxiliaires mécanisée demain
matin c'est une chimère ça n'a pas de
sens et même après demain matin c'est
toujours une chimère donc la manière
dont on a vu la chose dans le plan de
transformation de l'économie française
on l'a pas vue comme demain matin on se
passe de machines
ce qu'on croit c'est qu'il va y avoir
progressivement dans un certain nombre
de domaines plus de tâches qui devront
être qu'ils devront favoriser le
rendement agronomique et non pas le
rendement économique entre l'arrivée de
la machine est là
eu un double objectif dans certains
domaines par exemple les grandes
cultures ça évidemment favorisé le
rendement agronomique je vous rappelle
que le rendement des céréales à
l'hectare en france au sortir de la
guerre ils étaient quatre à cinq fois
inférieur à ce qu'il était aujourd'hui
est en fait aujourd'hui il n'est pas
très supérieur à ce qu'il était déjà il
ya 40 il ya 30 ou 40 ans donc ça a fait
un énorme bond en avant pendant toutes
les trente glorieuses avec l'arrivée de
la mécanisation des engrais et les
phytosanitaires
alors est ce que demain matin on va
abandonner tout ça non je n'y crois pas
une seconde est ce que on peut se mettre
dans une dynamique dans laquelle on fait
progressivement avec moins la réponse
est oui et ça va beaucoup c est sa
demande de toucher à plusieurs
compartiments du système alors je vais
vous donner un exemple
qui vaut ce qu'il vaut mais
on dit aujourd'hui avec la guerre en
ukraine on va avoir un problème de
disponibilité de produits agricoles
vous avez une bonne partie du sud ouest
qui cultive du maïs le maïs ne sert qu'à
l'alimentation animale je pense qu'il ya
d'autres céréales qu'on pourrait
cultiver dans les veines champs ou
d'autres cultures de protéagineux pois
chiches j'en sais rien
avec évidemment pas les mêmes rendements
mais qui pourrait servir directement à
l'alimentation humaine et compte tenu du
taux de conversion du maïs en protéines
animales qui se balade entre 2 et 10
selon qu'on regarde la volaille ou des
bruns
et bien il y aurait probablement les
moyens de concilier à la fois des
rendements qui n'augmentent pas et de
quoi nourrir des gens et en fait c'est
un peu la philosophie qu'on a dans le
tfc pas c'est pas pour rien que dans le
pdf on propose de diminuer la part des
produits d'origine animale dans la
ration alimentaire on propose pas du
tout de les supprimer on compose de les
diminuer parce que ça libère des
surfaces etc surface du coup on peut en
faire l'une des choses suivantes on peut
en faire de l' agriculture plus
intensive en emploi mais pas
nécessairement plus
poussée j'ai envie de dire mécaniquement
et chimiquement
on peut en faire de la biodiversité
c'est on peut voir rater de cultiver et
dire puisqu'on n'a plus besoin de
cultiver on laisse la paix aux petites
bêtes on peut en faire des matériaux
parce que vous avez une concurrence
d'usagé des sols pour faire également dû
alors que ton pas tellement chez nous
mais du lin et du chanvre dubois donc du
matériau où on peut s'en servir pour
faire de l'énergie est alors la première
énergie que nous pensons qu'il est
pertinent de faire à partir de culture
c'est celle qui alimente précisément les
auxiliaires mécanique de l'agriculture
qu'à titre personnel je pense que de
faire de biogaz pour l'injecter dans le
réseau pour chauffer des habitations
c'est pas ce qu'on peut faire de mieux
on pourrait très bien supprimer les
chaudières à gaz durée c'est ce qu'on
propose un plan de transformation de
l'économie française pour les remplacer
par des pompes à chaleur et se servir du
bio gaz pour alimenter tant qu'il en a
besoin la mécanisation des exploitations
agricoles elle même la première
utilisation la plus pertinente du biogaz
c'est un substitut aux carburants
fossiles importées pour les auxiliaires
mécanique des agriculteurs tant que la
moitié de la population française ne
rêve pas de retourner travailler les
champs et aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'elle rêve c'est parce qu'elle rêve de
faire déjà ils habitent en ville c'est
compliqué travailler les champs quand on
habite en ville il ya un sujet de
déplacements organisés des lieux de
résidence pour renforcer la population
rurale donc tout ça c'est des trucs qui
prennent du temps c'est pour ça que la
disparition de la mécanisation ça ne va
pas se faire et d'une manière générale
le montre jamais blanc et noirs donc
c'est quelque chose mais l'évolution
générale à encourager vers effectivement
une augmentation de la main d'oeuvre
dans l'agriculture parce qu'il ya
certains types de cultures pour lesquels
par contre le rendement agronomique
suppose un peu moins de mécanisation et
un peu plus de main d'oeuvre notamment
dans le maraîchage notamment
éventuellement dans l'arboriculture
notamment dans certaines techniques
d'agroforesterie etc
voilà il ya également des besoins de
main d'oeuvre pour un certain nombre de
choses qui sont écologiquement
pertinente par exemple y installer des
skis et c'est quelque chose qui nous
paraît pertinent à la fois pour
stabiliser les sols pour resservir avec
des eaux que sa fin quand des
auxiliaires biologique qui vont lutter
contre les prédateurs en vrac certain
nombre davantage à faire ça
et donc ça veut dire de moins en moins
ça veut pas dire la disparition la
disparition totale il y avait également
une question en filigrane derrière
l'ukraine qui était qu'est ce que je
pense d'eux du mouvement actuel qui
consiste à dire on oublie tous ces trucs
là on va y retourner à fond mais c'est
ça je pense que c'est un très mauvais
service à alors d'abord je pense que
c'est pas nécessaire pour assurer la
sécurité alimentaire s'est pas
nécessaire si on veut assurer la
sécurité alimentaire il ya bien d'autres
choses auxquelles il faut toucher
d'abord il ya un système d échange
domestiques basés sur des prix issus des
marchés mondiaux qui est un truc
extrêmement discutable de mon point de
vue donc je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui n'a pas de pertinence et ça ça
n'a rien à voir avec la question des
rendements agricoles par contre cela a
beaucoup à voir avec la désorganisation
les jeunes économique quand il commence
à y avoir un petit pépin chez un pays
exportateur
juste pour vous fixez les ordres de
grandeur si vous les connaissez pas la
russie et l'ukraine c'est 30% des
exportations de blé dans le monde mais
les exportations de blé dans le monde de
mémoire c'est 15% de la production
mondiale de blé donc le marché mondial
des céréales est un marché étroit par
rapport à la totalité de la production
mondiale et pourtant c'est ces
marchés-là qui fixe les prix directeur
pour les échanges domestique ce qui est
de mon point de vue est un système qui
n'a aucune espèce de pertinence
et ça c'est pas un preuve de rembourser
un prêt de ses impacts d'organisation du
système qui fait alors c'est compliqué
de le modifier parce qu'on irait pas
scander liés par des tas de traités
internationaux
parce que la compétence agricoles en
europe c'est l'europe justement ce pas
la france mais bref mais c'est c'est à
ça qu'il faut s'attaquer à ce que ça
c'est des conventions humaine donc c'est
ensemble qu'il faut s'attaquer
le
lead est par ailleurs de continuer à
laisser l'agriculture dans un état de
dépendance accrue aux combustibles
fossiles pour répondre à un problème né
d'un pays qui nous livre des
combustibles fossiles me paraît aussi
pas nécessairement être enfin pas de
serre en prendre le problème par le bon
bout il me semble que il faut au
contraire en profiter pour accélérer la
réflexion sur comment est ce qu'on fait
fonctionner le système agricole en le
rendant plus résilient à la baisse de
disponibilité des combustibles fossiles
parce que ce qu'on est en train
d'observer en cependant sur le prix du
gaz pour les jeunes dans cette salle et
en espérant vous vivrez aussi longtemps
que moi c'est que la première fois que
vous le voyez
mais le gaz il est épuisable le pétrole
il est épuisable et c'est assez facile
de comprendre que si on reste dépendant
d'une ressource épuisable
le prix de cette ressource alors
contrairement à ce qu'on croit souvent
il va pas croître indéfiniment
il va devenir indéfiniment volatile
c'est à dire qu'ils croient jusqu'au
moment où il détruit de la demande à ce
moment il baisse puisse a reçu site un
peu de demandes à ce moment ils
remontent enfin bref c'est donc il va
devenir volatiles imprévisible et mais
on va passer de plus en plus souvent du
coup par des épisodes dans lequel le gaz
vaudra une fortune du coup les engrais
azotés vaudront une fortune et le diesel
du tracteur vaudra une fortune et puis
après on va à peine arrivé un jour à une
époque où non seulement ça vaudra cher
mais des fois il y en aura plus du tout
parce que on répondre à ce genre de
stress par des rationnements ou et c'est
donc le rationnement il peut être
ennuyeux dans le champ mais il peut être
ennuyé en dehors du champ je vous disais
tout à l'heure un tiers des camions
transportent quelque chose qui se mange
donc si je rassure les carburants en
dehors du champ ça peut quand même être
gênant pour le champ parce qu'il n'ya
plus les transports aval pour faire en
sorte que le système continue à
fonctionner normalement voilà donc je
pense que c'est aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
péril en la demeure sur le niveau de
production agricole pour être capable de
nourrir des gens
et donc il faut surtout pas
si c'est mon avis que vous demandez
prendre prétexte de ce qui est en train
de se passer en ce moment en dix ans en
fait c'est juste un tout petit machin
puis après on est reparti pour 30 ans de
tranquillité donc surtout ne tenons pas
compte de ce signal d' alerte il me
semble que c'est l'exact inverse ce
qu'il faut faire il faut bien voir ça
comme un signal d' alerte et donc en
profiter pour accélérer la manière dont
on va réorganiser le système
très bien merci vous avez rapidement
évoqué la question des productions
animales et c'est justement l'objet de
la prochaine question qui est posée par
nicolas
bonjour la production de viande
représente 8 % des émissions de co2 en
france le ppf préconise de la diviser
par trois or la viande comme
l'illustrent la déclaration du candidat
fabien roussel au sujet du steak frites
est un bien de consommation est acquis
social alors comment rendre cette
proposition socialement acceptable pour
le consommateur
en outre la plupart des candidats
propose de revaloriser la filière de
l'élevage qui connaît des difficultés
concrètement comment accompagner cette
filière dans sa transition je vais
commencer par répondre à la deuxième
question et après je demanderai la
première dans ce n'est pas juste que
parce que c'est plus j'aimerais dire
technique sur la deuxième ce qu'on
imagine comme
comme système en ce qui concerne la
deuxième question c'est à dire comment
faire en sorte que une division par
trois des produits d'élevage ne conduise
pas à une multiplication par trois du
nombre de suicides d'éleveurs ce qu'on
pense faire c'est un système qui
ressemble un petit peu à ce qui se passe
dans le cadre des énergies renouvelables
c'est à dire des prix garantis contre
cahier des charges de type label donc en
gros on divise on diminue fortement la
production de produits d'origine animale
on met des cahiers des charges exigeant
sur la qualité de cette production est
la contrepartie de ces cahiers des
charges c'est qu'on multiplie le prix en
sortie d'élevage par trois en gros c'est
sale c'est ça l'idée l'idée générale
c'est pas nécessairement quelque chose
qui est aujourd'hui compatible avec les
dispositions de la pac
donc je leur disais tout à l'heure mais
l'appât qui a été fait pour organiser
initialement la pas que c'était fait
pour produire plus pour l'art dans un
monde qui ne connaissait pas de limites
physiques donc il faut également et ça
c'est une des difficultés auxquelles
nous sommes confrontés aujourd'hui
revisitée le mandat européen qui a pas
été fait pour fonctionner correctement
dans le monde finit
juste une petite 1,6 pour celles et ceux
d'entre vous qui ne seraient pas au
courant la constitution européenne
c'est-à-dire le traité de lisbonne est
probablement une des rares constitution
au monde qui contient le haut croissance
je ne pense pas qu'il y ait beaucoup de
constitution de pays dans lequel il soit
écrit le pays vise la croissance en tout
cas c'est pas dans la constitution
française ça j'en suis sûr et bien c'est
dans l'article 3 du traité de lisbonne
c'est à dire que l'europe s'est dotée
d'une constitution quel traité de
lisbonne c'est la constitution
européenne à cette traité qui régit le
l'existence de l'union et ce traité dit
l'europe dise la croissance ce qui veut
dire que derrière toutes les
dispositions réglementaires que nous
avons en europe sont calés sur cet
objectif alors ça marche moyen dans un
monde limité dans lequel ça va pas durer
en fait la croissance c'est déjà un peu
mis aux abonnés absents depuis
maintenant une grosse dizaine d'années
si on regarde les vrais flux physiques
pas trop les artefacts mais les vrais
flics donc on a alors pourquoi je fais
cet incident parce qu'on ne peut pas
faire l'économie du débat européen si on
veut s'occuper correctement de
l'agriculture puisque précisément
l'agriculture est une compétence
européenne c'est pas une compétence
subsidiaire où les états font ce qu'ils
veulent
donc ça va être un long ils ont une
longue histoire parce que ça voilà et ça
doit nécessairement passer parce que
l'europe est une construction
remontantes par la volonté très ferme
d'au moins quelques états dont un des
états fondateurs de dire maintenant
c'est dans cette direction qu'il faut
partir et aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le
cas clairement voilà donc la mécanique à
laquelle on pense un bien évidemment
encore une fois se
met beaucoup plus de valeur ajoutée dans
le kilo de viande qui continuera
toujours à être produit et par ailleurs
éventuellement demander aux éleveurs des
services écosystémiques pour lesquelles
il pourra être rémunéré en tant que tel
je parlais des est tout à l'heure
en ce qui concerne le et enfin dernier
point dans les modes d'élevage compense
pertinent de conserver dans ce genre de
monde c'est évidemment les bottes
d'élevage un peu extensif donc c'est le
pâturage c'est les autres de montagne
enfin cédé en gros toute façon on va
jamais mettre les champs bléou unis
mènent des jambes et du ldd charte
poireau
donc c'est ça c'est ça un peu l'idée
sur le premier point la déclaration de
fabien roussel en fait elle illustre à
quel point le système et ça je vais rien
vous apprendre l'alimentation est un
sujet culturel
les habitudes alimentaires sont
extrêmement variables en fonction des
pays du reste c'est bien pour ça qu'on a
des restaurants de cuisine étrangère
entre ça rigolo et sympa parce que c'est
pas du tout nos habitudes à 12 sa nuque
sort est touché à l'alimentation c'est
toucher aux habitudes culturelles et
toucher aux habitudes culturelles ces
deux générations c'est comme ça donc
c'est clair que
et fabien roussel il est comme moi il
n'est pas vraiment du côté de
l'innovation ont vu son âge donc il va
falloir
travailler cette question
culturellement pour se convaincre que de
manger moins de viande c'est pas quelque
chose qui est une régression
mais que c'est quelque chose qui peut
être vu comme un point positif dans un
monde qui évolue mais il n'y a pas de
bonnes il n'y a pas d'autres bonnes
réponses qu enfin de mon point de vue
qu'une réponse qui se situe sur le plan
culturel parce que c'est vraiment là je
veux dire l'île en manger moins et ne
pas en manger du tout ces deux choses
qui sont différentes et là on dit juste
faudra en manger moins et ça n'a
normalement pas de conséquences
sanitaires majeurs
c'est vraiment un sujet culturel
très bien maintenant prendre une
question de la part du club si vous avez
une question alors oui exactement on a
une question de quelqu'un qui expliquait
que l'agriculture c'est mécanisée parce
que produire avec des machines revenait
moins cher et qui demandaient comment
souhaitez-vous remplacer de
l'agriculture mécanisée part de
l'agriculture avec plus de main d'oeuvre
est-ce qu'il faut baisser les salaires
ou forcé plus de gens à aller travailler
dans le secteur agricole
est-ce que nous allons refaire des
kolkhozes
fabien ça pour ma retraite devient
patron de kolkhoze
je vais vous répondre avec un chiffre en
une minute en minute en une minute
l'agriculteur l'agriculture il y a alors
en une minute je vous répondrai pas
correctement donc je vous répondrais
qu'un chiffre entre l'agriculture
c'était il ya deux siècles à peu près
les deux tiers de la production
économique du pays aujourd'hui c'est 2%
de la production économique du pays et
donc pas une seconde on va modifier les
pratiques agricoles de manière
pertinente pour le problème qui nous
concerne si on ne remet pas de l'argent
dans le secteur et remettre de l'argent
dans le secteur ça veut dire que ça se
fera au détriment de l'argent que nous
allons mettre ailleurs donc un monde qui
se déclarent bonne sur le plan agricole
c'est un monde dans lequel il y aura
moins de smartphones - de t-shirts et
plus d'argent payées pour la nourriture
et à partir du moment où on part de ce
principe une partie de la question enfin
des problèmes sous jacents à la question
qui vient d'être posée on arrive à les
résoudre
alors on va maintenant passer à votre
sujet de prédilection il aisé l'énergie
mais en 15 secondes c'est culturel
c'est culturel c'est-à-dire que l'on
sait culturellement habitué à l'idée que
la nourriture devaient rien à voir donc
il va falloir mettre dans les esprits
que c'est pas le cas voilà un jeu
culturel
donc passons à l'énergie et maintenant
la commission européenne a donné un
label vert au nucléaire et au gaz le 2
février dernier et cette décision a
soulevé de nombreuses critiques révélant
les débats qui entourent l'énergie
aujourd'hui le pétrole le gaz et le
charbon sont les énergies prépondérante
et mais aussi les plus émettrices de co2
et dans le même temps la transition vers
les énergies les énergies renouvelables
et coûteuses et difficiles à mettre en
place et paradoxalement certains pays en
avance sur ce sujet comme l'allemagne
reste très dépendant aux énergies
fossiles
alors voici la première question sur le
mix énergétique avec le chiffre project
vous proposer dans le b tf1 mixte
comprenant énergies renouvelables et
nucléaires mais il existe d'autres
scénarios comme le rapport négawatt qui
vise les 100 % renouvelable
donc quelles sont d'après vous les
faiblesses du rapport négawatt et du
scénario 100% renouvelable
alors je vais pas pouvoir commenter le
rapport négawatt dans le détail parce
que il ya très longtemps que j'ai pas lu
les version actualisée du rapport
négawatt j'avais lu un des premiers et
après il ya très longtemps donc je vais
vous faire je vais vous répondre avec
quelques généralités la première
généralités c'est une question
j'invite les gens qui sont dans cette
salle à se poser la question
comment peut-on expliquer que nous
n'ayons jamais fait émerger une
civilisation de l'abondance matérielle
dans le monde 100 % renouvelable qui a
été celui connu par l'humanité depuis
son apparition jusqu'à il ya deux
siècles jusqu'à il ya deux siècles le
monde était 100% renouvelable et à aucun
moment dans ce monde là nous avons fait
apparaître de monde doivent pas de
système dans lequel il y avait à
profusion pour tout le monde des
vêtements de la nourriture des machines
à laver des logements
des trains des tirs ça existait pas
question pourquoi est ce que c'est parce
que les gens étaient idiots est ce que
c'est parce qu'ils étaient mal organisés
ou est ce que il ya quelque chose de
physique dans le monde de l'énergie qui
fait que un monde 100 % renouvelable
possède des limites et on va avoir du
mal à la
avoir un nom qui ressemble à peu près à
celui qu'on a aujourd'hui dans un monde
sans qu'on s'en va parce que un monde
qui ressemble pas du tout à celui qu'on
a aujourd'hui c'est en concert de
clavecin pose aucun problème
si on veut faire un saut de deux siècles
en arrière
voilà on était il ya deux siècles en
arrière on était un milliard donc on tue
sept milliards de personnes les autres
voilà physiquement ça pose pas de
problème
est ce qu'on sait faire un monde 100 %
renouvelable pour 8 milliards
d'individus avec quelque chose qui
ressemble à peu près à ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui
80 % de la population en ville
même 70% même 60 aller pour cent avec la
possibilité de changer de vêtements
assez facilement avec la possibilité
c'est ça c'est une question à laquelle à
mon avis la réponse est malheureusement
non
le dans le dans le cas ce que vous venez
dire sur le site project concerne la
partie électricité or l'électricité
aujourd'hui c'est à peu près 20% de
l'énergie qui alimente le parc de
machines que nous avons dans le monde
aujourd'hui nous vivons dans un monde de
machines non parce qu'on vous a demandé
de voir une conférence vous avez à peu
près compris ça sinon c'est dans cet
excellent bouquin jaune là donc on vit
dans un monde de machines et l'énergie
c'est rien d'autre que de la nourriture
pour machines et bien la nourriture pour
machines se compose dans le monde
aujourd'hui de 20% d'électricité et de
80% d'autres choses essentiellement des
dérivés des combustibles fossiles et
même dans l'électricité en fait nous
avons aussi beaucoup de dérivés des
combustibles fossiles puisque les 2 60%
aujourd'hui d'électricité dans le monde
est faite avec du charbon et du gaz gaz
fossile
donc là
ce système là il faut évidemment le
changer il faut essayer de passer à un
système dans lequel on utilise moins les
combustibles fossiles alors ce qu'on dit
dans plan de transformation de
l'économie française c'est que si on
utilise moins les combustibles fossiles
il nous reste deux carte notre
disposition qui sont les nucléaire parce
qu'en fait plusieurs manières de faire
du nucléaire et les renouvelables et là
aussi il ya une grande diversité dans
les renouvelables puisque entre une
éolienne de l'hydroélectricité et un
poêle à bois on n'est pas en train de
parler exactement des mêmes choses avec
exactement le même potentiel les mêmes
conditions d'utilisation etc faire
avancer un tracteur avec un poêle à bois
se compliquer alors que faire avancer un
tracteur électrique avec une éolienne on
peut on peut l'envisager donc on a
regardé à la fois comment ils évoluent
est la partie hors électricité et la
partie électricité et ce qu'on voit
comme beaucoup de gens donc ça c'est un
truc qu'on partage avec négawatt c'est
que un monde qui se déclare john est un
monde qui devient essentiellement
électrique
vous avez un peu de vecteurs issus de la
biomasse donc un peu d'agrocarburants et
un peu de biogaz mais pas beaucoup pas
beaucoup à cause de ce que j'ai dit tout
à l'heure parce que ces ressources là
sont en compétition d'usagé des sols
avec l'agriculture avec la biodiversité
avec la forêt et que nous allons avoir
besoin pour plein d'autres retraités
avec la biodiversité et que nous allons
avoir besoin aussi de forêt pour avoir
du matériau de l'université parce que si
on est la seule espèce vivante sur terre
on restera pas très longtemps et enfin
nous allons avoir besoin également
d'autres matériaux et de deux ans j'ai
donc là l'essentiel du vecteur est
électrique alors une fois qu'on a dit ça
la question c'est comment est ce qu'on
fait la plus grande quantité
d'électricité décarbonée possible et là
il ya un débat qui enflamme les foules
qui est souvent le débat auquel les
médias réduisent le débat énergétique
qui est nucléaire versus renouvelables
et en fait quand ils disent
renouvelables c'est une partie des
renouvelables parce que là tant il met
pas les poêles à bois et il met pas le
biogaz il met l'éolien le solaire
c'est à peine s'il pense à
l'hydroélectricité qui reste de loin la
plus grande source d'électricité
renouvelable dans le monde aujourd'hui
o'shea project on a on a pris le
problème sous l'angle pragmatique
suivant qui est de dire nous les
nucléaire on n'a rien autres en termes
d'inconvénients environnementaux en fait
le nucléaire a un énorme avantage sur le
plan environnemental c'est qu'il est
compact pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur qu'en vous fissionner un gramme
d'uranium vous libérer la même quantité
d'énergie thermique que quand vous
brûler une tonne de pétrole 1 gramme
d'uranium une tonne de pétrole ce qui
veut dire que l'énergie nucléaire a
cette particularité de produire de
grandes quantités d'énergie en
manipulant de petites quantités de
matière et si vous manipulez de petites
quantités de matières ça veut dire dowd
empreinte au sol ça veut dire d'autres
matériaux même si vous avez besoin de
ceinture et bretelles et des mètres de
béton et que vous prenez vous mettez du
retard à faire tout ça c'est pas grave
vous avez besoin de plug matériaux pour
exploiter cette énergie comparativement
à d'autres et vous fait même si c'est
des cochonneries peu de déchet parce que
vous utilisez des petites quantités de
matières donc du coup ça donne des
petites quantités de déchets
vous avez un
de l'autre côté les nerfs solaire et
éolien elles ont l'inconvénient
d'utiliser des sources qui sont diffuses
donc abondante mais diffuse parce que
sur 1 mètre carré il n'y a pas
énormément d'énergie solaire qui tombe
et dans un véhicule blanc vous n'avez
pas énormément d'énergie cinétique donc
ça veut dire que si vous utilisez ces
énergies là vous avez besoin de
collecteurs en grande quantité et dont
vous avez besoin d' espaces et surtout
de matériaux
et comme par ailleurs c'est pas des
sources pilotable vous avez besoin de
compléter votre système avec d'autres
dispositifs qui viennent en plus qui ont
besoin de le compléter dans les deux cas
de figure vous avez des paris à prendre
c'est à dire que sur le nucléaire vous
avez un appareil apprendre qu'ils aient
la certitude d'y arriver dans les délais
votre carrière à ce moment est une
barrière de compétences ses affaires une
centrale c'est un truc compliqué par
contre une fois que vous avez fait une
centrale c'était plein d'électricité
et bien la faire pour être sûr que vous
aurez pas trop d'emmerdements y compris
si ça va de travers sa demande d'avoir
une réglementation qui soient mises au
bon niveau ni trop compliqué sinon vous
faites pas parce qu'ils seront obligés
de faire ni trop
cool ni trop tolérante parce que sinon
vous risquez d'avoir des ennuis si
j'avais eu une défaillance donc il faut
ajuster les bêtes et m bon niveau donc
la barrière du nucléaire est une
barrière de compétence la barrière des
renouvelables et solaires et éoliens est
une barrière de matériaux et de capacité
à gérer le système
aujourd'hui on a créé un monde pilotable
c'est à dire que la conférence ici elle
a démarré à 14 heures qui est du vent ou
pas de vent du soleil ou pas de soleil
a décidé que ça démarre à 14 heures les
cours quand il démarre vous avez un
emploi du temps de l'année et on n'a pas
décidé dans cet établissement que
c'était virgule s'il ya du vent c'est
les cours ils sont peut-être jour à
telle heure et c'est comme ça que ça
s'organise si vous prenez un rendez vous
chez le dentiste on vous dira pas
attendez la roulette aujourd'hui marche
pas parce qu a pas de vent donc repasser
demain matin ou repassé la semaine
prochaine quand vous planifiez vos
vacances le train il va partir le 3
juillet à 2 heures du matin qui est du
vent ou pas de vent et qui est du soleil
ou pas de soleil et c'est donc toutes
les usines fonctionnent avec des
horaires et la société entière
fonctionne avec des horaires on peut
très bien revenir à un contrat social où
il n'y a plus des airs
pour le vin on peut le faire
physiquement il n'y a pas de problème
mais aujourd'hui c'est pas ça qu'on a en
tête quand on pense passer aux
renouvelables on pense passer à un
système dans lequel on conserve cette
caractéristique de la société qui est de
fonctionner avec des horaires et là il
ya un pari à prendre qui est d'y arriver
ou pas parce que l'on aura ou pas les
matériaux qu'on a pas en france a en
france on apporte tout de métaux il n'ya
pas évident en france 1 donc même si on
fabriquait les éoliennes chez nous on
devrait apporter l'acier le cuivre etc
qui permet donc on apporte tout
donc on devrait avoir les métaux et on
devrait avoir les dispositifs qui sont
des dispositifs compliqué de stockage de
ces rats de gestion de la fréquence de
gestion du loup dans tous les cas de
figure c'est prendre des paris est
aujourd'hui dans tous les cas de figure
une partie de ces paris se prend à
l'aveuglé
c'est à dire que si on fait le pari de
foncer sur le nucléaire comme proposent
certains candidats il ya un petit côté à
l'aveuglé parce qu'il faut être sûr
qu'on a dans les temps les compétences
la réglementation et on pourrait très
bien sûr sur les os les éoliennes là le
gouvernement a dit on va faire sauter
certaines procédures de recours histoire
que ça aille plus vite on est très bien
dire sur nucléaire on va faire sauter
les débats préalables ça sert juste à
discuter discuter on s'en fout donc pas
fonds gagne 5 ans sur le déploiement bon
est ce que la société y est prête
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas donc si on y
va ça veut dire que l'on prend par
exemple paris que la société un jour
acceptera ce genre de trucs bon
peut-être que oui peut-être que non bon
donc le quel que soit en gros la
direction comprennent aujourd'hui une
partie des question n'est pas résolue et
c'est toute la difficulté est donc c'est
pour ça que dans le ppfc là je voulais
en venir dans le système électrique que
nous préconisons il ya une partie quand
on est sur scène les centrales
existantes on les garde aussi longtemps
qu'on peut et le aussi longtemps qu on
peut c'est un peu de condition de
sécurité on précise le et c'est bon mais
parce qu'on a trop attendu pour faire
que du nouveau nucléaire on met des
oeillères pour partie aussi mais il ya
un gros paquet sur lequel on a mis un
point d'interrogation parce qu'on
considère aujourd'hui quelle que soit
l'option qu'on puisse prendre il ya des
paris associé sur lesquels on serait pas
confortable à dire c'est sûr qu'il faut
faire comme ça et il faut encore
instruire la question donc en fait la
conclusion première qu'on en tire c'est
qu'il ya un certain nombre de questions
sans réponse aujourd'hui qu'il faut être
capable d'instruire et je vais finir
avec juste une remarque nous avons
jusqu'à maintenant planifier l'avenir
pour un monde calme sans rupture or
depuis cinq ans on s'est tapé le break
site trump le coït la guerre en ukraine
et c'est que le début de la liste c'est
que le début de la liste parce que dans
un monde contre 1 ça c'est de la
tectonique des plaques d'une certaine
manière vous allez avoir un nombre de
craquements qui va augmenter avec le
temps c'est comme ça il faut il faut
vous y faire et moi aussi comme ça que
ça se passe et il faut être sûr que le
système électrique qu'on construit il
soit résilient à défaut
d'approvisionnement donc si on a plus
suffisamment de cuivre pour remplacer
les éoliennes ou les panneaux solaires
qu'est ce qu'on fait voilà il faut être
sûr que de pouvoir répondre à ces
questions là aujourd'hui la
planification la scénarisation qu'on a
faits y compris celle de négawatt ne
traite pas de ce point là et nous ce
qu'on dit juste c'est nous non plus on
n'a pas de traité
par contre il est urgent de le traiter
c'est à dire qu'il est urgent de faire
des tests de sensibilité ou des tests de
robustesse quelque part sur les paris
qu' on va prendre et éventuellement d'en
tirer des conséquences
une des conséquences qu'on va peut-être
devoir en tirer c'est qu'il ya des zones
de confort qu'on a aujourd'hui comme par
exemple de discuter pendant des siècles
avant de décider si on va faire qu'il
faudra partiellement abandonné parce que
sinon on fera rien du tout voilà c'est
donc ça va être des choix difficiles
peut-être une partie des gens dans la
salle vont dire comment ça il est anti
démocratique ce mec là il faut qu'on
arrête de discuter je sais pas je dis
qu'on va rentrer dans un monde pas
facile on va entrer dans un monde pas
facile ou les modes de fonctionnement
qu'on avait jusqu'à maintenant
peuvent nous faire prendre énormément de
risques parce que ils nous donnent
l'illusion qu'on a le temps alors qu'on
l'a pas et donc à ce moment c'est des
crises externe qui réguleront le système
à notre place
alors maintenant on va passer à la
question dans thonon
alors la russie étant dans les premiers
exportateurs de pétrole est le deuxième
exportateur de gaz à l'europe et la
france sont ainsi extrêmement dépendants
des ressources internationales avec la
guerre en ukraine on vit en ce moment
une hausse du prix des carburants est
elle uniquement liée au conflit ou est
il seulement un accélérateur de ceux qui
devaient fatalement à rêver alors là je
peux répondre d'une minute c'est la
deuxième option
c'est la deuxième option on a publié une
étude très fouillée au chiffre project
il ya maintenant un an sur les
perspectives d'approvisionnement en
pétrole de l'union européenne pour les
30 ans qui viennent alors pour ça on s'y
est pris comment on a été tirée par la
manche l'ancien patron de l'exploration
total l'ancien patron de l'évaluation
des gisements de chez total et l'ancien
analyste pétrole et gaz de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie aie ont
leurs amis entre les pattes une base de
données de l'ensemble des gisements de
pétrole dans le monde exploiter ou pas
ils ont leur a dit racontez nous ce que
vous pensez qu'on va avoir comme
production de pétrole en provenance des
16 premiers fournisseurs de l'europe
dans les 30 ans qui viennent et la
réponse est que ça fait sens
donc en fait la guerre en ukraine elle
n'est qu'un accélérateur de l'histoire
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
pour l'agriculture mais ça va être vrai
pour les transports à farah et les
transports ça va être vrai pour la
société dans son ensemble nous allons
devoir faire avec beaucoup moins pétrole
pour être très concret dans le travail
qui nous a été livré la production de
pétrole des 16 premiers fournisseurs de
l'europe qui sont par ailleurs les 16
premiers producteurs de pétrole dans le
monde or brésil et canada
cette production est divisé par deux
entre maintenant et de vie de 50 essais
la production or ces pays vont garder
une fraction croissante de leur
production pour leur propre population
ce qui veut dire que leurs exportations
vont être divisés par n'importe quoi
entre 2 et 10
et donc de toute façon nous allons en
avoir de moins en moins alors ça se
traduira soit par des hausses de prix
soit par des rationnements on est
habitué nous qui sommes nés dans
l'économie de marché à penser que les
problèmes de moindres disponibilités ça
conduit uniquement à des hausses de prix
mais que nenni les plus anciens dans
cette salle se rappelleront peut-être
que ça peut très bien conduire à ce
qu'on appelle un rationnement donc à un
moment on vous dit bien les avis vous
avez 15 litres de carburant par semaine
et puis démerdez vous avec ça
et là c'est plus un problème de cette
meilleure preuve de rien c'est un
problème de quantité
un jour ou l'autre ça finira par arriver
je ne sais pas encore comment mais un
jour ou l'autre ça paraît peu probable
que ça finisse pas par revenir
sur le gaz il va se passer la même chose
la russie nous fournit encore une fois
40 % de notre gaz et le gaz en général
la production gaz est en décalage d'une
dizaine d'années par rapport à la
production de pétrole le gaz et le
pétrole se trouve dans les mêmes
formations géologiques ils sont formés
au même moment à partir de la maine
matières premières organiques dans les
mêmes formations géologiques la raison
pour laquelle le gaz est en décalage par
rapport au pétrole c'est que
historiquement les pétroliers quand ils
trouvaient du gaz il trouvait pas ça
drôle du tout il ça leur plaisait pas du
tout ils savaient rien en faire parce
que quand vous trouvez du gaz au milieu
de la pampa et que vous n'avez pas de
gazoduc va vous savez pas quoi en faire
et puis de l'autre côté des
consommateurs de gaz y en avait pas tant
que ça maintenant il ya des
consommateurs de gaz à la fois pour le
chauffage et pour l'électricité ça les
intéresse plus et donc ils ont exprimé
son be on va dire à développer le gaz
avec un décalage de 10 ans par rapport
au pétrole donc puisque ce que disent
les experts du secteur c'est que le pic
de production mondiale de gaz devrait
suivre le pic de production mondiale du
pétrole avec un décalage
10 à 15 ans elle
d'accord donc maintenant on va passer à
la question sur les programmes
politiques posés par la ram
certains candidats à la présidentielle
veulent fortement augmenté la part de
l'énergie nucléaire dans notre mix
énergétique
pour ce faire il prévoit de construire 2
6 2 paires d'ici 2035 donc pour russel
et pécresse à 14 terre d'ici 2050 pour
macro et moore et encore le pen donc la
question est dans ce cas de figure au vu
de la difficulté de la mise en place de
ces réacteurs quelle énergie décarbonée
choisir d'ici à ce qu'il soit
opérationnel sachant que la plupart de
ces candidats ne prévoit pas de miser
sur la sobriété énergétique
bah en fait j'ai déjà répondu un peu à
cette question tout à l'heure c'est un
point d'interrogation
je vais quand même rajouter une
précision en fait si opm ans d'ici à
2035 ou 14 p r d'ici à 2050 pour autant
ça correspond à une baisse de la part du
nucléaire dans la production électrique
parce que dans le même temps une partie
des réacteurs qui sont actuellement en
fonctionnement seront en service au
moment où on construit un réacteur ils
étaient ils sont ici on va dire une
solide ils sont prévus pour fonctionner
quelques décennies lequel qu étant un
sujet de débat on a souvent entendu en
france là le comment dire la durée de 40
ans en visant les réacteurs sont
construits pour durer 40 ans elle en
fait ce n'est pas aussi simple que ça le
réacteur il est révisé à tous les dix
ans il ya une vie de l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire qui décide si oui ou
non le réacteur il est bon pour le
service pour dix ans supplémentaires
donc en fait c'est comme un bail
au lieu que le bail il soit par durée de
neuf ans la votre bail les pâtures et de
10 ans et à la fin de chaque by on
regarde si on renouvelle ou pareil c'est
l'asn qui décide alors la sf des sites
plus exactement à quelles conditions
elle autorise la poursuite de
l'exploitation donc je veux bien mais
vous allez faire tel type de travaux
tels types de travaux ceux-ci ceux là où
elle peut dire il n'y est pas de
questions mais en général ce qu'elles
disent et je veux bien mais changer
pourrait aussi changer moi cela et c'est
avec par exemple
une information que peu de gens
connaissent qui est qu'au moment où
fessée drive a été fermé pour des
raisons politiques en fait c'était une
des centrales les plus rénové de france
parce que comme c'était une des
premières construites en fait on avait
déjà tout changé à l'intérieur sauf la
cuve le seul truc qu'on peut pas changer
c'est la cuve dans lequel est contenue
le coeur du réacteur et donc ça c'est
particulièrement surveillés mais tant
qu'elle tient bon temps que tant qu'il
n'y a pas de tank ya pas de fissure
dedans tant que tout va bien bas le
reste ça se change donc on change au fur
et à mesure du temps tout un tas de
trucs et de machins et à fessenheim on a
échangé que le truc et elle avait un des
meilleurs taux de disponibilité du parc
français a du reste donc là
donc les scénarios a6 et a6 et 14 en
fait c'est pas des scénarios de
croissance du nucléaire dans la dans le
mix électrique basse et en fait ça
renvoie la question précédente c'est à
dire aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on fait en
plus de ça il ya des gens qui ont des
intentions mais quand vous regardez ce
qui est matériellement faisable je leur
dis vous vous rendez compte que quelle
que soit l'option comprend il ya un pari
est que c'est inconfortable comme
situation parce que aucun embranchements
du pari n'est totalement instruits
alors maintenant c'est à vous de jouer
on va passer à la question des filles en
une minute donc si dans la salle
quelqu'un une question à poser pour
conclure cette thématique
on vous laisse la parole vous pouvez
juste levé la main et un micro viendra à
vous
si vous avez vraiment pas d'idée du tout
on peut quand même demandé au club cette
fois ci
personne
donc on va demander aux clubs
en ce qui concerne le nucléaire pourquoi
promouvoir encore cette énergie alors
que les centrales seront vulnérables
face aux changements climatiques comme
les inondations les incendies les le
réchauffement de l'eau qui est censée
les refroidir quel est votre avis
c'est encore et toujours la même réponse
c'est à dire que tout va présenter des
risques dans le monde futur il faut se
sortir de la tête l'idée qu'il ya des
options sans risquer des options avec
risque ça n'existe plus ça il n'y a que
des options avec risque du risque comme
10h et lucas l'humoriste la vie est
pleine de risques puisque on finit par
en mourir donc la bonne manière de voir
le problème c'est pas d'opposer un
nucléaire qui présenteraient des
inconvénients avec des alternatives qui
ne présenteraient aucun sens ça n'existe
pas ce qu'il faut faire c'est une
comparaison des avantages et des risques
et arbitrer en fonction ça voilà donc
mes mails à l'idée que le nucléaire est
plein d'inconvénients et en face il ya
des trucs qui n'ont que des avantages
malheureusement ça correspond pas à la
réalité
j'ai tenu en moins d'une minute c'est
incroyable
nous allons maintenant passer aux thèmes
suivants qui concerne l'industrie et le
numérique comme ça ne vous a sûrement
pas échappé nous sommes alors du tout
dématérialisé du tout automatique et de
nombreuses questions sur les flux de
données leur impact environnemental se
pose de plus une partie de la classe
politique candidate aux élections
prochaines ve réindustrialiser la france
pour lui assurer une certaine autonomie
vis-à-vis des autres pays notamment en
europe et réduire ses émissions de gaz à
effet de serre à l'importation ma
question est donc la suivante selon vous
peut-on miser sur l'industrie et
l'innovation technologique pour résoudre
les problèmes climatiques au travers de
techniques comme la géo-ingénierie
on n'est pas vraiment dans le numérique
la jeune âge amiri
[Rires]
est ce que tout le monde dans la salle a
une idée claire de ce que c'est que la
géo ingénierie
[Musique]
alors je vais peut-être commencer par
répondre à cette question la
géo-ingénierie c'est ça correspond à
l'idée qu'on pourrait maîtriser le
fonctionnement ou en tout cas une partie
du fonctionnement du système climatique
en agissant à large échelle sur
essentiellement l'irradiation solaire
dans les technologies qui sont
envisagées il y en a il y en a plusieurs
il ya des gens qui ont imaginé aller
lâche et du soufre en combustion dans la
haute atmosphère pour créer du dioxyde
de soufre conduisant lui même à des
petites particules de sulfate qui
réfléchirai la lumière solaire il ya des
gens qui ont pensé à les déployer des
miroirs à ce qu'on appelle le point de
lagrange qui est le point où
l'attraction vous savez de la terre et
du soleil sont des gars l'intensité
donc il serait en orbite stationnaire
donc d'aller déployés là-bas des grands
miroirs qui ferait que la terre recevrez
un peu moins d'énergie du soleil et
c'est ce genre de ce genre de
technologie des gens qui ont pensé à
mettre des petites paillettes pour
réfléchir des gens qui pensent en
semences et l'océan avec des oxydes de
fer histoire de favoriser la croissance
des algues qui ainsi pomperait plus vite
du co2 de l'atmosphère enfin bon bref il
ya tout un tas de trucs auxquels les
gens ont réfléchi
alors ça à plusieurs inconvénients ces
technologies là les premières c'est
qu'en général c'est des actions qu'il
faut répéter en permanence pour obtenir
l'effet déployer des miroirs dont enfin
il tient jusqu'au point des météorites
qui le percute mais sinon il tient mais
par contre si vous regardez la masse des
miroirs à déployer donc vous fait un
petit calcul tant de grandeur un compte
tenu de l'épaisseur d'un miroir que vous
devez que vous pouvez déplacer et que
vous regardez la quantité de fusée qu'il
faut garder dans l'espace pour allait
déployer quantité suffisante de miroirs
pour calmer un peu les radiations
solaires je sais que j'avais fait un
pack calcul d'ordre de grandeur il ya
très longtemps je m'en souviens plus
loin et on arrivait à quelque chose qui
était absurde c'est à dire que en fait
ça représentait un effort qui était
beaucoup trop important sur la partie
dioxyde de soufre dans la haute
atmosphère c'est un tout petit peu
gênant parce que ça fait des pluies
acides généralisée et par ailleurs petit
effet de bord est par ailleurs comme
l'atmosphère avec ceux des toits en
l'espace d'un à deux ans eh bien il faut
continuer à envoyer du soufre dans la
haute atmosphère en permanence et le
jour où vous arrêter non seulement vous
n'avez plus les faits atténuateur de
votre technologie mais encore la
température se réchauffe comme si vous
n'aviez jamais pris la moindre mesure
d'accord donc imaginons qu avec ce genre
de truc vous fassiez baisser la
température planétaire de un demi degré
puis vous continuer d'émettre du co2 à
fond les ballons
vous arrivez en mettant plus en plus de
dioxyde de soufre dans l'atmosphère a
laissé la température là où elle est le
joueur vous arrêter non seulement vous
gagnez le demi degré que vous aviez
gagné que vous alliez perdu au moment où
vous avez commencé votre mesure mais
vous gagnez en plus c'est l'évasion de
température qui aurait eu lieu à cause
du co2 émis si vous n'aviez rien fait
donc inutile de vous dire qu'à ce moment
vous prenez un énorme coup sur la tête
enfin voilà donc quand vous regardez les
mesures vous rendez compte qu'elles sont
pas qu'est ce qu'elles sont comment dire
problème en soi pas à l'échelle soit
qu'elles présentent des effets de bord
qui sont suffisamment importants pour
que on essaye de faire autrement
voilà donc la géo-ingénierie jeu
personnellement je pense qu'il faut être
assez prudent avec ce genre de choses
alors maintenant ça rentre aussi dans le
débat général qui est ce qu on a des
options sans risque à partir de
maintenant la réponse est non
donc il faut regarder des trucs un
parent et les éliminer ou voir si
éventuellement il ya un bon qu'on peut
prendre en fonction des options
super merci beaucoup je vais maintenant
donner la parole à lucile qui a là aussi
une question
bonjour excusez moi nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans l'ère du tout numérique
pensez vous qu'il faille en sortir du
fait de la consommation d'énergie et de
l'émission de gaz à effet de serre au
contraire il peut s'agir d'une solution
à certaines problématiques je pense par
exemple au télétravail qui peut limiter
les déplacements
là
alors aujourd'hui pour fixer les idées
l'empreinte carbone de l'ensemble des
technologies
enfin de ce qu'on appelle le système
digital sur terre c'est à peu près 4 %
des émissions mondiales c'est à peu près
la même chose que les émissions de la
flotte de camions dans le monde ça
augmente de 6 à 10% par an ça augmente
très rapidement et c'est essentiellement
tirée par un usage auquel je pense que
beaucoup d'entre vous sacrifie qui est
la vidéo en ligne
dans la vie donc enrôlé entre les deux
tiers et les trois quarts du trafic
internet c'est de la vidéo dans lesquels
vous avez en 4/4
vous avez netflix je sais pas s'il est
fixe favorise au télétravail un car vous
avez le porno un car je sais pas si t'as
favori le télétravail
vous avez youtube 1 1 car
si oui probablement que ça favorise un
peu le télétravail et enfin après vous
avez tout le reste c'est à dire les
vidéos de petit chat le petit dernier
qui vient de faire ça dans et qu'on
envoie à tout le monde qu'il s'en fout
royalement du reste et c'est donc voilà
le voilà en gros à quoi ressemble le ce
qui tire aujourd'hui
le
l'utilisation du système numérique et
l'utilisation est donc l'empreinte
carbone du système vous commencez à
avoir également de plus en plus d'objets
connectés
donc vous avez un frigo qui sonne quand
il est vide des pantoufles qui sonne
quand elles sont trop chaudes ni trop
froides le collier de votre chien qui
sonne quand ils s'éloignent à plus de 5
mètres enfin bon bref etc
je sais pas quoi votre bague de
fiançailles qui sonne à la
saint-valentin nourrir tout un tas de
trucs qui
tout un tas d'objets total pas d'objets
connectés
qui tire également les usages je ne suis
pas sûr que il favorise énormément de
télétravail dit qu'il favorise
énormément la baisse de la consommation
d'énergie donc aujourd'hui on va quand
même trouvé dans digital essentiellement
des gadgets
on va trouver du loisir pour l'essentiel
la partie du digital qui pourrait être
vraiment mises au service des économies
d'énergie c'est une petite fraction une
toute petite fraction du système digital
que nous avons alors oui vous trouvez
effectivement des thermostats pilotable
et des trucs comme ça mais c'est toute
petite partie et ça ne suppose pas du
tout de déployer les systèmes qu'on
déploie aujourd'hui pour prendre un
exemple dans l'actualité au moment où il
ya eu des débats sur le déploiement de
la 5g
j'ai entendu dire que c'était absolument
indispensable pour opérer du genou les
retraités qui se situait dans la creuse
oui je peux bien enfin vu le couple est
prêt à vendre la 5g ça coûte moins cher
de payer un jet privé pour les quelques
retraités en question pour les amener à
paris que de déployer le système mêmes
l'empreinte carbone sera plus faible
donc on a aujourd'hui en fait on la
vraie raison c'est free qui l'a donnée
avec ses campagnes en expliquant qu'on
allait faire la vidéo sur tender voilà
ça ça je veux bien ça c'est de
l'honnêteté
c'est pas du tout la vraie raison c'est
pas du tout qu'on en profite pour faire
des choses qui sont socialement très
utile on en profite surtout pour
disséminer des écrans de loisirs est
collé de plus en plus de smartphones et
d'écrans d'ordinateurs dans les pattes
de tout le monde que ce soit une bonne
ou une mauvaise chose c'est surtout à ça
que ça sert
donc ça ne sert pas aujourd'hui les
économies d'énergie et par ailleurs
c'est un système qui n'est pas très
résilient sais pas si vous avez vu dans
l'actualité il ya pas très longtemps
mais il ya eu pénurie de semi
conducteurs
alors cette pénurie de semi conducteurs
est là une première origine qui est à la
faveur du co vide on a justement
basculer sur des moyens numériques des
choses qu'avant on faisait pas par
moyens numériques et je suis frappé de
voir que dans les travaux enfin dans
tout l'univers professionnel de la vie
de bureau aujourd'hui la visioconférence
avec des inconnus est devenu dans c'est
à dire que ça n'a plus rien de
socialement répréhensible d'avoir un
premier contact avec des gens qu'on
connaît pas par visioconférence alors
qu'avant le coc vite ce n'était pas du
tout le cas c'est à dire que quand on
allait voir des gens pour la première
fois on leur rendait visite et on
faisait des visions avec ses
collaborateurs éventuellement quand on
était parti en vacances je sais pas quoi
c'était pas du tout un mode de
fonctionnement normal d'une réunion de
travail
donc sas a eu une conséquence c'est
qu'il ya une partie des composants
électroniques qui sont partis dans le
système télécom qui paye bien au
détriment des constructeurs de voitures
qui se sont retrouvés en pénurie on peut
électronique et qui ont vu leur
fabrication
amputé de 25% complètement ridicule ces
deux dernières années alors pourquoi je
vous dis ça parce que les composants
électroniques dans un ordinateur vous
avez 40 métaux différents donc le
système numérique il durera aussi
longtemps que les capacités minières
mondiales pour les métaux en question et
c'est un peu ennuyeux parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a plein de fonctions
qui sont essentiels dans la société à
commencer par l'existence d'une monnaie
qui sont devenus tributaires du
numérique aujourd'hui quand vous payez
vous utilisez un ordinateur donc en fait
aujourd'hui l'argent c'est devenu des
électrons en circulation dans un système
électronique c'est ça le et aujourd'hui
on n'est plus capable dans un pays comme
la france d'assurer la fonction la plus
régaliennes qui soit qui ait lever
l'impôt sans le concours des gaffes à
vous payer vos impôts par internet c'est
à dire que vous payez vos impôts etc et
gaffe à
la la dépendance d'un certain nombre de
fonctions essentielles au numérique
sacré les impasses
sacré les impasses notamment parce que
le numérique a des capacités de
traitement de l'information que nos
cervelles n'ont pas et si par exemple
demain matin on devait revenir au papier
au crayon pour tenir les comptabilités
de tous les établissements à commencer
par celui qui nous accueille et bien
faudrait un peu augmenté le nombre de
comptable j'avais pas si le budget
permettrait de les payer
content content vu la quantité
absolument faramineuse de voilà donc on
s'est rendu prisonnier aujourd'hui du
numérique pour des trucs qui sont
essentiels payer l'impôt assurer la
circulation de l'abonné assurer la
communication sur des choses absolument
essentiel
mon avis c'est là je voulais en venir
c'est que du coup il serait sage de ne
pas utiliser des ressources qui sont
épuisables pour regarder netflix en
ultra haute définition dans le métro on
peut très bien lire un magazine
parce que bouffon à vitesse accélérée
des ressources qui resteront longtemps
indispensable pour assurer des fonctions
qui sont considérablement plus
indispensable au fonctionnement de la
collectivité qui sont encore une fois
avoir huit modèles
avoir avoir des capacités d'organisation
à large échelle avoir un système de
télécommunications pour des informations
essentielles qui fonctionne à peu près
bien avoir des systèmes de productique
industriel parce que là c'est pareil on
peut se raconter ce qu'on veut avant que
demain matin il est plus une machine à
commande numérique dans l'industrie va
quand même se passer du temps
donc on a et puis il ya plein de moyens
de transport aujourd'hui qu'on n'est pas
foutu tiré sans le numérique donc ça
serait pertinent de garder les capacités
résiduelles mais là c'est en train de
faire un voeu pieux ne sais pas ce qu'il
va se passer mais ça serait intéressant
de garder les capacités résiduelles de
production de semi conducteurs
et de dispositifs numériques pour
assurer le plus longtemps possible
un certain nombre de fonctions
essentielles de la société alors
qu'aujourd'hui on pouffe la chandelle
par les 25 ou pour des usages qui sont
des usages j'ai envie de dire
récréatif donnée essentielle
merci beaucoup
on va passer à la dernière question de
ce thème à savoir la question de
chalenge par la question présidentielle
posée par max immédiat
bonjour monsieur jancovici donc comme ça
a été dit la majorité des candidats sont
pour la réindustrialisation de la france
pour des raisons stratégiques comme
l'indépendance vis-à-vis des autres pays
ou pour réduire les gaz à effet de serre
liées aux importations le pcf lui
prévoit plutôt une contraction
l'industrie en france et donc est ce que
selon vous ce sont deux visions
contradictoires et quelles seraient les
secteurs industriels à privilégier pour
atteindre nos objectifs climatiques
aujourd'hui l'industrie dans le monde
c'est en gros 16 % des émissions
mondiales si je prends les émissions
directes des procédés alors c'est quoi
les émissions directes des procédés
c'est des émissions directes de co2 des
hauts fourneaux et l'aciérie c'est à peu
près de 4 % des émissions mondiales
c'est les émissions directes des
cimenteries laisse le ciment ses 4 % des
émissions mondiales c'est les émissions
directes de la chimie de base
briquet notamment du plastique enfin on
va dire la chimie organique 1
savent pas que du plastique
et enfin le reste de l'industrie s'est
également 4 % des émissions mondiales
dans lesquels vous allez trouver
l'industrie agroalimentaire qui en
représente un paquet non négligeable
à cela il faut rajouter la production
électrique de l'électricité utilisée par
l'industrie qui vous rajoute en gros 10
% d'émissions supplémentaires donc là
les procédés industriels
fabrication des conduits dans la
fabrication des objets tout mouillé
c'est un quart à peu près des émissions
planétaires donc on n'atteindra pas la
neutralité carbone sans ramener ça à pas
loin de zéro et ramener ça à pas loin de
zéro ça veut dire que fatalement la
production industrielle mondiale va
diminuer
en france après la question est de
savoir où est-ce qu'elle va prendre
place il se trouve que la production
industrielle elle prend place au début
avec l'activité minière puisque la
totalité et l'activité d'extraction de
ressources de l'environnement
éventuellement de ressources biologiques
des fibres du bois etc
le aucune des extractions de ressources
minières ou d'hydrocarbures d'un lieu en
france maintenant sauf pour 1 % notre
pétrole donc la question de
l'indépendance de la france henri
industrialisable en france c'est un
débat relatif ce qu'on peut faire c'est
remonter dans l'échelle de valeur pour
se rapprocher de la ville mais la minute
on peut pas la transférer d'australie
chez nous pas très bien
par contre ce qu'on peut on peut quand
même réfléchir à est ce qu'il ya un
certain nombre d'étapes de valeur
ajoutée qu on pourrait par maître chez
nous à ce moment ça devient un sujet des
emplois ça devient un sujet de maîtrise
de la technologie chez nous c'est sait
il se discute que c'est complètement un
sujet d'indépendance c'est pas aussi
simple que ça
passe à l'est partiellement mais papa
pas en totalité dans le pdf on a
effectivement regarder comment est ce qu
on baissait les émissions de l'industrie
existantes en france et on s'est
concentré sur trois secteurs qui font
75% des émissions à 2,3 l'aciérie la
cimenterie la chimie de base donc on n'a
pas regardé l'industrie agro alimentaire
par exemple et sur ces trois secteurs on
a dit que la technologie pouvait faire
entre 50 et 80% du chemin en gros et la
sobriété allait faire le bout du chemin
il ya deux bouts du chemin restant à
sobriété ça veut dire quoi se dire par
exemple on va faire moins de ciment ça
veut dire par exemple fait en moins
d'acier ça veut dire par exemple faire
dans le plastique c'est de manière très
concrète c'est ça que ça veut dire
sur la question de la
réindustrialisation les angles morts des
propositions des candidats sont en
général les suivants si on ré
industrialiser ça veut dire qu'on va
augmenter la quantité d'énergie utilisée
par les industries qu'on relocalise en
france
la question est de savoir si cette
quantité d'énergie supplémentaire
demandé par les industries qu on
remettrait en france elle est pris sur
d'autres secteurs qui vont fortement
baissé leur consommation
où elle vient de manière additionnelle
par rapport à ce que nous avons déjà si
elle vient de manière additionnelle par
rapport à ce que nous avons déjà faut
être sûr que ce soit de l'énergie
décarbonée puisque cissé additionnel
c'est pas garanti que ce soit décarbonés
ça va dépendre de ce qu'on va faire
alors tout à l'heure on a eu longue
dissertation sur le réseau électrique
français
si on doit réindustrialiser la france ça
veut dire qu'il faut encore plus
d'électricité décarbonée que si on veut
juste avoir l'industrie qu'on a
aujourd'hui et donc la question se pose
encore plus de savoir comment on fait
cet indice est électricité
supplémentaires dhr je vais mettre les
pieds dans le plat tout de suite pour
bien me faire comprendre peut-être que
les gens qui disent qu'il faut
réindustrialiser la france ils sont
implicitement d'accord quel qu'il soit
avec le fait qu'il ya un certain nombre
de procédures préalables qu'il faut
faire sauter pour la construction des
réacteurs nucléaires des éoliennes et
les stockages de gaz peut-être
parce que sinon on a pas d'électricité
décarbonée qui est nécessaire enfin
voilà donc il faut il faut aujourd'hui
dans les programmes des candidats et des
candidates
c'est une intention général qui est
affiché ce qui est absolument certain
pour ce qu'on en a vu quand on aura
gardé les programmes c'est que y'a rien
de concret derrière il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas de plan derrière précisant les
secteurs précisant les échéances
précises en l'énergie associés et
précisant comment on la produit sarah
pour le moment ça n'existe pas
merci au cou donc cette fois nous allons
bien passer à la dernière question du
thème à savoir la question du chalenge
sur une minute
alors est ce qu'il y aurait donc cette
fois une idée dans la salle pour cette
question
oui oui il faut 17
bonjour du coup moi je viens danger et
hier j'étais la conférence de l'ademe
qui parlait de vouloir moins du coup
consommer et donc la question c'était de
cité sur la question de la sobriété
finalement puisque la dame a aussi fait
un rapport sur pour attendre le la
neutralité carbone en 2050 est donc
l'une des mesures qu'il préconise c'est
dans un premier temps de rénover tous
les tous les bâtiments qu'on a déjà est
ce que c'est quelque chose qui peut être
en corrélation avec votre épée du coup
de baisser l'industrie en lien avec les
bâtiments puisque on a nécessairement
besoin aussi de matériaux pour rénover
ses bâtiments qui dépensent énormément
d'énergie pour faire le lien avec la
séquence d'avion oui absolument
dans la partie logement du plan de
transformation de l'économie française
en fait la sobriété on l'a fait surtout
sur la construction de logements neufs
aujourd'hui on a deux fois plus de
logements neufs qui sont construits
chaque année qu'il ya de formation de
nouveaux ménages donc nous on dit faut
pc ça et c'est essentiellement là dessus
qu'on va faire de la sobriété la
rénovation c'est beaucoup beaucoup de
main d'oeuvre oui si vous faites venir
ici des artisans pour améliorer la
performance thermique de l'envelope donc
mettre du quintuple vitrage est plaqué
de l'isolant à l'extérieur des murs et
bien ça va vous surtout vous demandez
damas d'oeuvre est assez peu de
matériaux dont il n'y a pas de problème
à rénover massivement le bâtiment avec
20 on vous laisse avec la sobriété sa
pose pas trop de problème par contre
pour conjuguer la construction neuve
avec la sobriété là c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué et donc c'est pour ça qu'on
préconise de l'aide de diminuer la
construction de
huawei respect de 10 secondes incroyable
on va donc passer maintenant au lac à
trinité matic qui
qui concerne les transports alors que la
taxe carbone a soulevé une forte
contestation populaire il y a trois ans
les transports concentre beaucoup les
crispations autour des mesures
écologiques en effet ce secteur et vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure et mais 30%
fin et participe à 30% des émissions de
co2 de la france mais c'est également
aussi un secteur ayant une grande marge
de progression puisqu'ils utilisent très
majoritairement des énergies fossiles
donc la première question vous avez un
peu tepa situe tout à l'heure donc j'ai
que la pose est quand même bon on va
pouvoir y répondre ainsi brièvement elle
est la suivante c'est pensez vous qu'il
faut remplacer assure d'énergie des
voitures donc les verts de l'électrique
ou de l'hydrogène ou bien qu'il faut
plutôt dit ni leur diminuer leur nombre
est allé vers plutôt généraliste
généralisation des transports en commun
pardon est alors s il faudrait rendre
les rendre graphie pour qu'il soit
accessible à tous
alors ya plusieurs de ne plus plus une
question
juste la dernière tant qu'ils pensent
rendre les transports en commun gratuits
et une mauvaise idée c'est une
maintenance est une mauvaise idée qu'on
les rende éventuellement pas cher ça
c'est un débat mais qu'on y rendre
gratuit est une mauvaise idée parce que
les le constat des opérateurs de
services pas juste les transports dans
le monde sait que quand on rend les
services gratuits les gens ne respectent
plus le ils font pas attention voilà
donc il faut que les gens payent quelque
chose même si c'est symbolique il faut
que les gens paient un petit quelque
chose là après on peut très bien alors
des mécanismes tels c'est à dire que
l'on peut vous dire vous le payez lit
par ailleurs la collectivité sous
conditions de ressources ou les tuer
c'est déjà ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
du coup j'ai perdu les autres alors
est-ce qu'il faut moins de voitures et
plus d'electric bas ça j'ai déjà répondu
tout à l'heure donc les deux mon général
est-ce qu'il faut basculer sur les
transports en commun pas que
il faut tout un cocktail il ya aussi les
modes actifs après dans les transports
il ya un truc on oublie souvent c'est le
fret transport de marchandises et les
marchandises non pas de gens dont
quelque part c'est presque encore plus
urgent d'avoir de quoi basculer le
transport des marchandises sur des modes
décarbonés que le transport de personnes
parce que les gens ont des jambes donc
voyez pour venir bah oui pour venir de
l'idsa jusqu'ici j'ai pris une voiture
ce qui est très mal je ne dirais pas qui
conduisait
mais si on s'était organisé d'une autre
manière j'aurais mis une demi-heure de
plus chaque viol qui est fait les jambes
d'accord donc dans un monde sans pétrole
enfin exactement avec pas le pétrole de
cette voiture je me serais organiser
autrement il saurait passer quand même
alors que par contre ce que vous avez
mangé à midi c'est un pas de jambes et
donc il est impératif d'avoir des
camions pour vous le livrer sinon ça
marche pas donc la décarbonation du fret
est également quelque chose qui est
essentiel donc il ya un choc il ya
plusieurs chapitres dans ptf sur la
décarbonation les transports il ya un
chapitre sur l'industrie automobile il
ya un chapitre sur le fret ya un
chapitre sur la mobilité longue distance
et il ya un chapitre sur la mobilité du
quotidien et là je vais aussi en
profiter pour faire le distinguo
justement entre cette mobilité du
quotidien et la mobilité longue distance
les déterminants de ce qui nous fait
douter placé pour le quotidien j'ai
envie de dire n'ont rien à voir avec les
déterminants de la longue distance le
quotidien la moitié des déplacements
c'est ce qu'on appelle domicile travail
ou domicile études donc c'est le
déplacement comme seront lundi qu'entre
là où on habite et là mon travail ou là
on étudie à l'autre moitié c'est tout le
reste les courses les gars 1 allée à la
piscine à qu'est ce que je sais
c'est essentiellement ce qu'on appelle
des déplacements contraints c'est à dire
que rares sont les gens qui disent bon
bah le carburant est à 2 euros donc je
vais pas aller au travail à supposer
qu'ils puissent pas faire télétravail
voilà bonbons mon travail c'est d'aller
jeu pourquoi garder des gamins bah non
je te parlais garder les gamins parce
que
non les gens vous avez un travail vous y
allez donc ça fait partie des
déplacements contraints dans les
déplacements longue distance vous êtes
essentiellement dans des déplacements
choisi et de loisirs l'essentiel des
déplacements à longue distance à plus de
80 kilomètres du domicile le motive
c'est des loisirs le loisir c'est des
trois quarts des déplacements en avion
par exemple donc c'est le gros de la
clientèle de la sncf donc c'est pas le
gros de la contributeurs aux marges mais
ces gros de la clientèle en termes de
flux donc là le déterminant est pas du
tout le même les modes de transport
utilisés sont pas du tout les mêmes on
voit apparaître l'avion alors que dans
les déplacements du quotidien l'avion
est quand même assez rare
tu as quelques magnats qui ont un
hélicoptère pour faire 30 km mais quand
même ils sont assez rares
et donc les mesures qu'on préconise en
pdf sont pas du tout les mêmes donc pour
le déplacement du quotidien je le redis
on bascule vers un mélange de transport
en commun ferrer et dont ferrer là aussi
il ya un truc à avoir en tête c'est que
le transport en commun ferré dit lourd
il n'a de pertinence que quand vous
desservez les zones denses il ya une
règle du pouce qui est bien connu chez
les opérateurs de transport c du métro
on vous en fait quand vous êtes dans des
zones à 100 habitants ha jusqu'à 20
habitants ha vous faites du bus est en
dessous vous faites rien d'ailleurs vous
pouvez rien faire donc quand on
construit des zones pavillonnaires à
droite à gauche dans des zones à moins
de vingt habitants hectares il n'y aura
jamais de transport en commun pertinent
dans ce genre de zone j'avais il faut
savoir
c'est que ça donc c'est là
surtout que sur le basculement je leur
disais moins de voitures plus petites
électrifié
sur le fret on électrifie également les
boîtes de transport alors il ya
plusieurs manières de les électrifier on
peut électrifier les autoroutes on peut
pas skull électrifié d'autres ça veut
dire mettre des caténaires sur la voie
de droite et transformer les camions
entre les bus 1 en gros ça que ça veut
dire on peut passer sur la cyclo
logistique pour le dernier kilomètre
on peut basculer sur le train
de basculer sur le train c'est comme
pour l'agriculture tout à l'heure ça
induit plus de coûts de main-d'oeuvre
parce que vous avez des ruptures de
charge et donc ça vous fait des coûts
plus élevés et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle le fret ferroviaire a pas
arrêté de pc sur les 50 dernières années
c'est juste ça c'est que ça coûte plus
cher parce que ça demande plus de
main-d'oeuvre
et on ne décidera de leur ait augmenté
que par volonté politique en disant
c'est obligatoire il n'aura pas
tellement d'autres manières de s'en
sortir il faut également organiser la
gouvernance de tout ça au niveau du fret
1 dans le pdf on a des propositions sur
il faut on voudrait qu'il y ait une
agence nationale ou un bout de ministère
qui s'occupe du de la planification
d'ensemble de la réorganisation de la
logistique
d'implantation de plate forme et c'est
enfin bref tout ça et tout ça et de
certificat de capacité pour les
transporteurs enfin voir un certain
nombre de dispositifs à mettre mettre en
place
sur la partie longue distance ce qu'on
préconise c'est essentiellement pc
l'avion augmenter le train donc on
préconise notamment de construire encore
quelques lignes à grande vitesse pour
mailler les capitales européennes
et pour le reste eh bien nous irons
moins souvent sous les tropiques en
avion voilà c'est ses voiles ou alors
quand on ira ça prendra du temps et on
ira en bateau
le
basculement est essentielle il doit se
faire de la voiture et de l'avion vers
le train avec
avec des systèmes de mobilité locale
associée typiquement vous prenez un
billet de train pile vous louer un
véhicule quand vous arrivez destination
pour pour vous balader là où vous allez
voilà en gros la façon dont ça se soit
écrit dans le pdf prévient si c'était
très clair c'est constant ce qui a
poussé poser la prochaine question
bonjour les cieux gens qu ici dans le
pdf vous intéresser aux aménagements et
modes de déplacement en ville mais quel
est votre point de vue sur la situation
des campagnes où le déplacement en
voiture sont indispensables
quels aménagements ou alternatives pour
la ruralité envisagez-vous
la ruralité aujourd'hui si on prend les
gens qui habitent en tissu rural c'est
20 % de la population
donc
le l'objection souvent fait qu'ils aient
vous préconiser des mesures qui sont
inapplicables au tissu rural je vous
taquine un tout petit peu c'est un point
de vue très français consistant à
d'abord regarder ce qui marche pas au
lieu de regarder d'abord ce qui marche
ça ne doit pas faire oublier que 80% de
la population et dans un tissu de type
urbain ou périurbain ou là on peut très
bien faire avec beaucoup moins de
voitures avec toutes les mesures que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure pour le tissu
rural c'est évident qu'on va rester avec
de la voiture il faut qu'elle soit plus
petit et électrifié c'est sale c'est en
gros la principale mesure qu'il y aura
dans ces zones là et par ailleurs ce
qu'on a dit tout à l'heure sur le train
ou versus l'avion 20 quand une personne
habitant dans le monde rural décide
d'aller à bratislava pour le week-end
parce que ça arrive aussi eh bien il
faudra que la pratique cela en train
à supposer qu'elle dit rien aussi donc
sur les déplacements longue distance à
change pas grand chose
enfin ça change un peu mais pas grand
chose est sûre les déplacements du
quotidien c'est évident que dans ce
monde là il ya un un sujet de transport
mécanisé qui aujourd'hui se résoudra pas
en avec nous avec beaucoup moins de mode
individuel mécanisée mais par contre il
faut que ces modes individuel mécanisée
deviennent plus léger électrique et
très bien merci fait dès aujourd'hui on
constate que les véhicules électriques
se vend très bien dans le monde rural
quand renault a lancé c'est zoé il
pensait que ça allait être un deuxième
véhicule urbain et en fait ça s'est
avéré être souvent un premier véhicule
rurale
parce que les distances de déplacement
dans la journée c'est rare quand même
que dans le monde rural les gens fassent
plus de 250 km dans la journée
et ils ont une recharge chez eux et donc
ça correspond assez bien ici assez
économique pour les gros rouleurs
donc en fait ça on s'est rendu compte
que le véhicule électrique 100 %
électrique ce soir est très bien dans
mon couloir
très bien merci la prochaine question
est posée par un édit est et concerne le
transport aérien il me semble
bonjour monsieur jancovici donc voilà ma
question c'est les propositions
concernant les transports des candidats
sont toutes peu contraignante pour les
citoyens et ne concerne enfin et ne
nécessite pas de changement des
habitudes ou de l'aménagement urbain
elle se concentre surtout sur des taxes
et sur un transfert de une transition
des énergies fossiles à l'électrique
pour les bus et enfin les voitures et
les transports en commun des mesures
plus strictes comme des interdictions
par exemple pour l'avion comme proposait
déjà par messieurs jadot et mélenchon
sont elles nécessaires et inévitables
pour initier un véritable changement
dont on considère que oui
il y a
6 mois un an de ses parents fin en jeu
six mois rien dans cette fois pareil
pour moi
o'shea project on a sorti un rapport sur
l'aérien qui s'appelait paul et en 2050
alors en fait ce rapport il a surtout
été fait par des gens du monde aérien
donc c'est vos homologues un peu plus
vieux se souvent ils étaient en activité
sortie de super héros
trou équivalent donc travaillant dans
cet univers là qu'ils se sont posé la
question de savoir comment est ce qu'on
pouvait mettre le transport aérien lui
aussi en harmonie avec l'anglais
l'accord de paris c'est-à-dire moins 5%
de baisse les émissions tous les ans est
la conclusion à laquelle ils sont
arrivés c'est que c'était impossible
sans baisser progressivement trafic et
donc en gros on ne peut pas tout à
l'heure j'ai pas répondu sur l'hydrogène
oui je suis désolé là ça peut être la
question à huit minutes tout à l'heure
l'hydrogène on compte absolument pas
dessus dans les transports c'est quelque
chose qui est enfin voila je pourrais y
répondre tout à l'heure si ça si ça vous
intéresse mais on est dans les
transports ça restera du gadget
donc la la
qu'est ce que tu as donc sur le sur la
partie aérienne on ne voit pas en
faisant les calculs 1 en regardant les
mêmes on embarque en tout ce que la
technique peut nous offrir des avions un
peu plus efficace on d'électrifier
toutes les opérations au sol par exemple
le roulage se fait avec des taxis
électriques
l'avion il utilise pas son propre
carburant pour générer son d'électricité
quand il égaré au parking mais il
utilise une prise électrique tout ce
qu'on peut il n'empêche que on n'arrive
pas à te dire c'est moins 5% par an sans
que le trafic baisse et une conclusion
très intéressante du travail qui avait
été fait également part par les auteurs
de ce rapport c'est que plus on
attendait pour enclencher la baisse est
plus il y aurait de la casse sociale sur
la durée au moment où la baisse arrive
involontairement c'était intéressant en
conclusion ça veut dire qu'en gros si on
est soucieux de l'emploi dans le secteur
le grand paradoxe moi moi qui attendais
pas du tout le grand paradoxe c'est que
il faut justement ne pas attendre que
les événements extérieurs de décident
pour nous et progressivement baisser le
trafic ça veut pas nécessairement dire
que ça va mettre au chômage des gens
partout et tout le temps alors dans les
compagnies aériennes elle même assez
clair que si vous avez moins d'avions
vous avez moins de personnel navigant
dans les avions par contre dans le dans
l'industrie aéronautique pendant un
temps ce n'est pas nécessairement vrai
parce que ça veut dire que vous avez une
rotation accélérée des avions pour les
remplacer aussi vite que possible par
des appareils qui consomment moins
il faut savoir qu'un avion les émissions
de fabrication d'un avion c 1 % de ses
émissions en fonctionnement un avion
c'est un gros réservoir de kérosène
volant donc le fabriquer en termes de
gaz à effet de serre ça coûte rien par
rapport au fait que le fait de le faire
voler donc en fait plus vous le
remplacez souvent par un truc qui
consomment moins et sur le plan
strictement co2 et plus et pertinents
donc en gros vous avez intérêt à
accélérer la cadence dans les chefs
d'airbus à condition que ce soit pas
dans un contexte de trafic croissant
et que ce soit vraiment pas pour
accroître sa flotte mais pour remplacer
les appareils existants
ce qu'on allait également
ajouter comme mesure même si l'essentiel
du kérosène et conservé dans les longs
courriers donc voilà donc on avait on
avait mis deux mesures dans le pdf nous
on en a une sur les long-courriers et
moyen-courriers qui est de limiter le
nombre de créneaux de décollage des
aéroports français et ans comme le dit
mais des acolytes du chiffre injecte les
atterrissages autant vous voulez juste
décollage
et donc le
alors après évidemment la bonne question
c'est dans un monde comme cela comment
est-ce qu'on gère la pénurie qu'on fait
apparaître et alors il ya de manière de
la gérer et ça ça renvoie des choix
éthiques ou bien on laisse les
opérateurs se démerder et à ce moment
ils vont tous les prix et à ce moment il
ya de moins en moins de gens qui ont les
moyens de s'offrir l'avion ou bien on
règle ça de manière un peu plus
communiste c'est à dire que l'on dit il
ya moins de vols en avion pour tout le
monde mais chaque droit de chaque
français est un droit de tirage sa vie
durant le cas de vol en avion qu'ils
soient riches ou pauvres peu importe
et il a le droit de prendre quatre fois
l'avion et c'est un droit qui lui a
octroyé par la collectivité et ça change
pas en fonction de vos revenus
les français ont en général une
préférence pour le 2ème genre de règles
que le premier jeu dans de rennes
et puis en ce qui concerne les vols dits
cours
on pensait nouveau chip project
interdire tout simplement les vols en
avion dès lors que les destinations sont
accessibles à moins de quatre heures et
demie de train alors pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a pris quatre heures et demie il
se trouve que à carbone 4 on a fait il
ya quelques années une étude qui a
montré que sur un certain nombre de
destinations européennes
quand vous étiez à
trois heures et demie de train le temps
global pour un déplacement en avion
était le même si vous teniez compte du
fait d'aller à l'aéroport de vous de
passer du temps à vous faire papouiller
pour vérifier que vous n'avez pas une
bombe l'enclos votre culotte plus à
l'arrivée le temps d'aller récupérer les
bagages est ce qu'on appelle le temps de
post acheminements qui consiste à vous
rendre de l'aéroport qui en général et
pas sur la place du centre du village
jusque là où vous allez on a constaté
que sur paris amsterdam par exemple
c'était équivalent d'y aller en train ou
en avion et on s'est dit si on n'est pas
prêts a rajouté une heure par rapport à
ça pour éviter de tous rôtir c'est
vraiment con et un foutu de faire le
moindre effort donc on est passé de 3
heures et demie à 4h30 voilà c'est ça
c'est ça le la logique et sur les
capitales européennes je renvoie ce que
je disais tout à l'heure il faut manier
les capitales européennes avec des
trains soit bonne nuit soit rapide de
telle sorte que une bonne partie des
vols intra-européens on soit capable de
les réaliser sans avion et sans trop
souffrir en france la règle dès 4h30 ne
maintient qu'une destinations
domestiques significatif c'est pareil ce
qui dans toutes les autres disparaissent
ok pour la question je me suis remis
dire mais si vous voulez parler du de
l'hydrogène dans les minutes ou a
soufflé une autre question je peux vous
parler de l'angel en dix minutes par
hydrogène l'hydrogène alors je suis
désolé je vais vous à une minute à
l'hydrogène a la particularité d'être un
carburant
extrêmement dense par unité de poids
c'est pour ça que quand vous l'utilisez
dans une fusée qui doit s'arracher à la
gravitation c'est ça que vous utilisez
mais extrêmement peu denses par unité de
volume et c'est pour ça que quand vous
êtes d'abord limitée par le volume ou
utilisés par hydrogène qui est un
carburant extrêmement peu efficace pour
ce genre de choses or les transports
terrestres et les transports aériens
sont d'abord limitée par des questions
de volumes pour le transport aérien un
peu moins mais le transport terrestre
oui parce que vous n'avez pas
l'intention de traîner un tank derrière
vous citerne derrière vous et
l'hydrogène quand vous déplacer en
bagnole donc l'hydrogène dans les
transports terrestres on n'y croit
absolument pas la manière dont on voit
l'hydrogène dans le plan de
transformation de l'économie française
c'est comme matière première uniquement
produite par électrolyse avec de
l'électricité décarbonés pour faire deux
choses une qui vous concerne directement
ses des engrais une deuxième qui vous
concerne directement aux donc
l'hydrogène sert à l'ammoniaque qui sert
aux engrais comment il savait et le
deuxième qui vous concerne indirectement
sélassié aujourd'hui on produit le faire
en réduisant du minerai de fer avec du
charbon c'est ça qu'on fait dans les
hauts fourneaux et nous on propose de
réduire le minerai de fer avec de
l'hydrogène et à ce moment ça fait que
l'eau est du reste arcelor un projet
d'investissement à tokai massif pour
faire ce genre de choses mais il faut un
réacteur nucléaire pour produire
l'électricité décarbonés pas aux
fourneaux que l'on en place et ils en
ont 3 ou 4 je crois à dunkerque
merci donc maintenant on va passer à
l'avant dernière séquence sur le social
le changement climatique accentue les
inégalités les pays pauvres sont plus
vulnérables car davantage exposées aux
nouveaux aléas et avec des populations
moins protégés et au sein même des pays
riches les personnes les plus pauvres et
démunis sont souvent davantage
souffrent davantage des impacts du
changement climatique que les autres et
pourtant leur empreinte carbone est bien
moindre dans ce climat inégalités les
réformes en faveur de l'écologie sont
encore souvent punitive et suscite donc
de vives réactions des citoyens ce
contexte ralenti les actions qui
pourraient être menées en faveur d'une
transition d'où la question sur notre
système démocratique
vous avez dit à propos de la démocratie
qu'elle était un système myope lent et
souvent incohérents et qu'on ne répondra
pas aux changements climatiques sans
l'usagé contrainte diriez vous que la
démocratie actuelle est ainsi un mauvais
système tant qu'une transition ait lieu
et pensez vous alors que des changements
peuvent se faire sans l'approbation
d'une majorité
en démocratie que des changements
puissent se faire sans l'approbation
d'une majorité non ou en tout cas sans
l'acceptation ex post d'une majorité non
ensuite en ce qui concerne la contrainte
oui je il ya quand même quelque chose
sur lequel il faut pas se raconter
d'histoires
respecter les limites environnementales
c'est accepter la restriction
par construction c'est accepter la
restriction
c'est accepter la finitude c'est
accepter la restriction d'une certaine
manière dont on eu l'idée qu'on puisse
ne pas avoir
quoi que ce soit comme règles
restreignant un usage si on entend se
préoccuper d'environnement ça ne peut
pas exister alors des gens disent c'est
positif
parce que c'est punitif d'avoir
l'obligation de venir en cours ici
on va dire que non
j'ai passé positif est ce que c'est une
restriction votre liberté bah oui parce
que si vous venez en courbe a du coup
vous allez par la piscine vous n'allez
pas boire des bières et vous n'allez pas
faire un tour à vélo donc oui c'est
restrictif voilà donc est-ce qu'il peut
y avoir une construction sociale sans
restriction non vous connaissez
probablement cette maxime célèbre qui
est la liberté des uns s'arrête là où
commence celle des autres et bien quand
on fait intervenir l'environnement dans
l'équation la liberté des autres prend
plus de place
c'est la collectivité qui s'impose un
peu plus ou détriment de nos libertés
individuelles c'est comme ça donc la
bonne question c'est c'est quoi les
systèmes avec lesquels on est à l'aise
pour gérer ces restrictions qu'on a
derrière alors je vais rapidement évoqué
tout à l'heure
nous sommes ainsi big band et en france
qui est le seul pays communistes
d'europe de l'ouest pour plus facilement
acceptée la contrainte réglementaire que
la contrainte économique alors d'abord
les bizarreries sur lequel j'aimerais
juste faire une petit 1,6 quand il a été
question de taxer le carburant pour
éviter d'en consommer trop de nous mêmes
la taxe carbone les gilets jaunes sont
descendus dans la rue est ce que vous
voyez des gens dans la rue en ce moment
avec le carburant à deux euros le litre
dans les sols gilet jaune là c'est ce
qui pose des questions
alors c'est quand même hallucinant quand
vous y pensez parce que dans le premier
cas de figure la taxe carbone c'est quoi
c'est une fiscalité donc c'est un impôt
qu'on se prélève sur nous mêmes et qu'on
recycle dans le pays
donc cet impôt sert par exemple à payer
vos études
par exemple donc dans un premier cas de
figure on dit on va limiter un usage qui
est nocif pour l'environnement et qui
nous fait dépendre d'une ressource
épuisable en gardant l'argent chez nous
et les gens disent non non j'en veux pas
et puis là on est dans un contexte dans
lequel on dit le prix de l'essence
augmente parce qu'il ya plus d'argent
qui fout l'camp hors de france pour
payer les producteurs de pétrole a
commencé par monsieur poutine et les
gens d'y jouer au hockey devant soi je
supporte
on est tous tombés sur la tête
collectivement
donc la bonne question c'est qu'est ce
qui fait qu'on est incapable de
comprendre un raisonnement alors moi je
sais en fait ce qu'il fait c'est que
dans le cas de poutine c'est la fatalité
et la fatalité c'est la faute à personne
alors que dans le cas de l'augmentation
des impôts cessé avant tout politique
qui comprennent rien à rien qu'ils
viennent de piquer notre pognon donc en
fait c'est pas de temps la logique
économique qui est remise en cause c'est
le degré de confiance qu'on accorde aux
dépositaires de la gestion de la maison
commune c'est ça le problème est en fait
j'ai fait ce petit chemin de traverse
pour en revenir à un point qui est que
les français et les françaises
considèrent généralement la contrainte
réglementaire comme plus justes et plus
lisible et moins susceptibles de passe
droit que le la contrainte fiscale ou
économique
je vais prendre un exemple supposons que
l'on veuille la fin des chaudières à
fuel dans ce pays il ya deux options la
première est de dire je vais taxer le
fioul et à ce moment votre jeune
camarade là qui m'a posé la question sur
le monde rural ce à deux mains en l'air
en disant le monde rural qui surfent au
fuel assassins du monde rural qu est ce
que vous êtes et c'est bon
deuxième option je dis pas je vais axer
le fioul je dis je vais interdire les
chaudières à fuel et sous conditions de
ressources c'est très exactement ce
qu'on a à faire je paye une pompe à
chaleur aux gens qu'on pas le moyen de
remplacer leur chaudière à fuel par une
pompe à chaleur donc là j'ai une voie
réglementaire vous êtes riche vous êtes
pauvre façon ça sera interdit d'avoir
une chaudière à fuel et si vous êtes
pauvre la collectivité vous aident à
acquérir un moyen de chauffage
alternatif ça ça passe les gens
descendent pas dans la rue etc ça me
fait dire une chose ça me fait dire
alors que pourtant j'étais très très
favorable à la taxe carbone il ya
presque vingt ans puisque avec mon
associé à carbone 4 actuel alain
grandjean on avait écrit ensemble nos
fiançailles ça a été d'écrire ensemble
un bouquin qui s'appelait le plein s'il
vous plaît dans lequel quitte une
déclaration d'amour à taxe carbone taxe
carbone c'est formidable alors en fait
ça aurait été formidable si on s'était
pris à 20 ans sap la fiscalité c'est un
instrument un peu douloureux à manier
avec précaution et donc il faut
augmenter progressivement pour que ça
pour que ce soit efficace il faut qu'on
ait le temps devant soirée que ça ça
bouge progressivement
le différentiel de taxation sur les
carburants entre l'essence et le diesel
a fortement diésélisé le parc français
en 30 ans donc la taxe ça marche bien si
vous avez 30 ou 40 ans devant vous si
vous n'avez pas trente ou quarante ans
devant vous il faut procéder par des
moyens plus rapides et les moyens plus
rapides sont des moyens réglementaires
donc maintenant on a plus la visite
l'infini devant nous donc il faut
essentiellement de mon point de vue y
aller par des moyens réglementaires et
les moyens réglementaires sont des
moyens qui sont vus par les français
comme étant plus équitable donc ça
renvoie à la question de l'équité etc si
on dit aux gens que votre cave 1 soit
riche ou que votre gamin soient pauvres
de toute façon il mangera du pool à une
fois par semaine à la cantine et bien la
population trouve ça plus juste que si
on dit on va taxer de poulet et puis si
vous appelez bill gates vous en foutez
continue à manger s'il voulait par jour
si ça vous amuse voilà c'est c'est donc
je pense que la wii a par ailleurs un
sujet dans la restriction un sujet
d'équité qui est absolument essentiel ça
on accepte la restriction à partir c'est
le fameux c'est pas juste 1 pourquoi lui
et pas moi pourquoi elle et pas moi et c
est la meilleure réponse à la justice
dans ce genre de cas de figure encore
une fois parce beaucoup plus souvent
paradoxalement par la norme que par le
prix d'art dire exemple on dit pas si
vous êtes pris en excès de vitesse vous
allez payer
une amende qui vous arrivera rien
d'autre si on vous retire des points bas
que vous soyez riche ou pauvre vous
risquez des points c'est beaucoup plus
équitable
d'accord merci la question suivante sera
posée par matteo
bonjour vous avez l'habitude de dire que
l'explosion démographique qu'on a connue
a été rendu possible grâce à une
situation d'abondance énergétique or on
va très rapidement tendre vers les 10
milliards d'habitants sur terre est-ce
que selon vous cette démographie va être
un obstacle à la transition et est-ce
que nécessaire de prendre des mesures
qui vont enfin de briser un tabou social
en france d'enfants en brisant notamment
quand je voulais parler des
du contrôle des naissances voilà à deux
des mesures malthusienne vol d'accord
alors le contrôle des naissances ça
existe déjà aujourd'hui 1
ça s'appelle la contraception et ça ça
fait de l'avortement
donc donc vous n'avez donc vous n'avez
pas
on ne sait pas aussi simple que un monde
dans lequel on refuserait d'en parler
partout et tout le temps et un monde
dans lequel on en aurait déjà parlé
partout et tout le temps un peu plus
nuancé que ça après c'est aussi un sujet
qui est foncièrement culturel c'est un
sujet qui vient se heurter au sujet
moureu aux sujets religieux
donc cdc des sujets pas ça alors
première
première question est ce qu'être 8 ou 10
milliards sur terre c'est un problème
contenu
du sujet dont on parle est à l'évidence
oui vous savez probablement ce que c'est
qu'une boîte de pétri ici est bien plus
de bactéries dans la boîte de pétri et
plus vite la boîte de pétri sera bouffé
donc oui c'est évidemment un sujet donc
la terre est une grosse boîte de pétri
et si on est 8 milliards dans la boîte
de pétri basse et on a moins d espace
que si on est un milliard et on a moins
de marge de manoeuvre c'est absolument
évident et on risque plus vite d'avoir
des mécanismes de régulation
involontaire qui nous feront retomber à
moins 2 milliards
tout aussi évident
une fois qu'on a dit ça on n'a rien dit
parce que effectivement la bonne
question c'est quelles sont les moyens
de concilier la morale les credo
religieux nos pulsions primaires et la
question de la population
alors jeune en jeûnant je n'en vois que
deux à ce stade
l'une des deux m'a valu une volée de
bois vert d'un certain nombre de gens la
première c'est de
d'améliorer la possibilité pour les
femmes qui ne veulent pas d'enfant de ne
pas en avoir
quand on discute avec un homme s'appelle
gaël giraud je vous cite son nom pas
parce que j'ai honte de mes convictions
parce que je trouve que c'est
intéressant de voir qui peut soutenir ce
genre de choses donc à evirons et d'un
père jésuite et pendant un temps il a
été chef économiste de l'afd il ya une
vidéo qui tombe sur internet dont vous
pouvez la retrouver et avec ça alors
qu'il était à l'afd il a dit si on était
sérieux sur la question de l'aide au
développement
la quasi totalité de l'aide au
développement devrait être dirigée sur
trois mesures parce que le premier
service qu'on peut rendre aux pays
émergents c'est de maîtriser leur
démographie avec des moyens qui sont par
éprouvés par la morale est le premier
moyen par éprouvés par la morale c'est
la possibilité pour les femmes qui le
veulent de ne pas avoir d'enfant et il
disait il ya trois choses qu'il faudrait
faire c'est toutes les mesures qui
permettent aux femmes de mieux maîtriser
leur propre destin la formation le les
sujets d'égalité et c'est le deuxième
sujet c'est la contraception
est alors qu'ida peut commencer à poser
des problèmes d'ordre moral ou religieux
un bien évidemment et enfin le troisième
sujet c'est la mise en place de systèmes
de solidarité à large échelle parce que
tant que vous n'avez pas de système de
solidarité à large échelle assurance
maladie retraites eh bien c'est la
cellule familiale qui s'en charge et à
ce moment le réflexe est de faire autant
d'enfants vous pouvez en disant vous
disant que si vous êtes vieux ou malades
il ya bien quelqu'un là dedans qui va
s'occuper de vos vieux jours
donc ces jeux jeux personnellement je
souscris à cette vision de la chose
alors ça fera pas passer la population
urbaine de 8 milliard à 2 milliards dans
les 30 ans qui viennent mais ça peut au
moins éviter d'ajouter une partie
supplémentaire de la pression parce que
de fait plus on est nombreux la taille
du gâteau ne variant pas et plus la part
de gâteau pour chacun est petit et si
elle devient suffisamment petites pour
que ça devienne un sujet de friction
majeur eh bien ça augmente la
convivialité du monde et les risques
qu'il se passe des choses désagréables
derrière la deuxième chose alors ça
touche pas très vite à la démographie ce
que je veux dire par ailleurs et c'est
un c'est un débat un peu un peu
supplémentaire j'ai envie de dire c'est
le rapport à la mort que nous avons dans
les pays occidentaux on a aujourd'hui un
rapport à la mort qui est que toute mort
est intolérable donc vous avez beau
avoir 100 ans est grabataire intubé dans
tous les sens alors maintenant c'est un
peu moins vrai mais quand même il ya un
sujet qui est c'est d'abord reste
quelque chose qui est intolérable
et je pense qu'il va falloir en sortir
c'est à dire que je pense qu'il va
falloir accepter d'avoir un autre
rapport à l'abord la considérer comme
pas illégitime dans un certain nombre de
cas de figure quand j'étais gamin il y
avait une expression qui s'appelait
mourir de vieillesse et qui avait une
connotation qui était mourir de sa belle
mort
belle mort quoi ça voulait bien dire ce
que ça voulait dire ça veut dire qu'il y
avait des manières pas illégitime mourir
trop jeune c'était injuste c'est mais
bourillon vieux bois c'était normal
litigieux horrible et donc c'est
aujourd'hui on en est sorti parce que
toutes les mains en cause technique
donc on les médecins se voit comme des
plombiers du corps et donc s'il ya un
truc qui philippe boucher et
alors ça va pas directement influé sur
la démographie
a prêté l'air mais s'est associé à un
sujet démographique qui est le
vieillissement de la population et le
partage des ressources résiduelles entre
eux est ce que je m'en sers pour
maintenir en vie des gens très vieux où
est ce que je pensais pour les genres
votre âge voilà et ça je pense que c'est
un débat de société auquel on échappera
pas
merci la question présidentielle va être
posée par alban
donc rebonjour ce jancovici la première
priorité des français étant le pouvoir
d'achat de nombreux candidats proposent
promettent de l'augmenter or cela pousse
à la hausse de la consommation donc de
l'utilisation d'énergie ce qui va à
contresens de la décarbonation donc la
question c'est la suivante est-ce qu'on
peut concilier l'augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat et la baisse des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre
difficilement vous avez une alors le
pouvoir d'achat il faut c'est le comme
son nom l'indiqué c'est le pouvoir
d'acheter les pour acheter faut que ça
existe donc en fait le pouvoir d'achat
c'est aussi de pouvoir le produire si
vous regardez physiquement comment les
choses s'organisent en fait on peut pas
acheter un truc qui n'existe pas enfin
montant si vous voulez acheter un
vêtement faut qu'il y ait été produit
si vous voulez acheter un mètre carré de
moquette il faut qu'il ait été produit
si vous voulez acheter une pension
frites il faut qu'elles aient été
produites et même si vous voulez acheter
une place de cinéma il faut qu on
déconstruit le cinéma et qu'on veut
tourner le film donc il ya déjà des
idées en fait on peut pas acheter
quelque chose qui n'a pas été produit et
en fait l'expression pouvoir d'achat on
la traduit de manière monétaire mais
c'est une traduction imparfaite en fait
ça veut surtout dire c'est le pouvoir de
vivre dans une société de l'abondance
matérielle ou cette abondance matérielle
vous est accessible mais pour qu'elle
vous soit accessible faut qu'elles
existent donc là le vrai défaut de cette
promesse des candidats c'est en fait
avant même que
il y aurait une contradiction avec les
émissions sait déjà qu'il ya une
contradiction avec la possibilité
éventuellement physique d'augmenter la
production or aujourd'hui il se trouve
que nous y sommes déjà la production
industrielle dans le monde occidental
n'est pas plus élevés aujourd'hui
qu'elle ne l'était en 2008 2008 année où
le monde a passé son pic de production
du pétrole conventionnel si vous
regardez le nombre de mètres carrés
construits en europe aujourd'hui par an
il est inférieur à ce qu'il était en
2007 donc si votre pouvoir d'achat c'est
par exemple le pouvoir d'avoir un
logement eh bien il n'est déjà plus
faible aujourd'hui pour des raisons
physiques pour des raisons physiques
qu'il l'était en 2007
et ça va s'amplifier ça va s'amplifier
parce que comme je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure l'europe est en décrue subi
d'approvisionnement en pétrole et pour
des raisons identiques elle est en
décrue subi dès à présent
d'approvisionnement en gaz et ont décru
subit aussi d'approvisionnement en
charbon en tendance évidemment ça veut
dire que l'europe est aujourd'hui en
décrue subi de production
industrielle domestique elle est
également
contrainte sur la quantité
d'approvisionnement enfin d'importation
qu'elle va pouvoir faire en ne veillant
pas à port d'envaux un temps indéfini ça
veut dire que la simple promesse qu'il
va y avoir une abondance matérielle
croissante avant même de savoir si elle
sera accessible est aujourd'hui une
promesse qui est non seulement risqué
mais à mon avis impossible à tenir
alors qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
dans ce genre de contexte il me semble
qu'il faudrait arrêter de prendre les
gens pour des andouilles et leur dire
non mais vraiment et leur dire la
réalité c'est que vous allez lire mois
pour gérer au mieux un système dans
lequel il ya des trucs sur lesquels j'ai
pas de prise et les trucs sur lesquels
j'ai pas de prise c'est ça ça et ça
parce que ça dépend d'un bond de
physique dans lequel moi j'ai pas de
prise là je suis pas complètement
convaincu qu'aujourd'hui la population
serait totalement rétives
à quelque chose qui serait un discours
un peu responsable et on en revient à ce
moment à la question qui a été posée
tout à l'heure qui est s'il n'est pas
possible d'avoir plus c'est quoi les
mesures les plus équitables avec
lesquels je me sens confortable dans un
monde dans lequel il y aura globalement
un peu moins voilà c'est quoi c'est quoi
les mesures et donc si on m'explique que
c'est un monde dans lequel bois pour
pouvoir préserver de quoi m'habiller de
quoi payer mon loyer je vais tondre un
peu plus vite le type qui a un suv qui
sera prié de rouler en vélo peut-être
que ça enfin voila mais il va falloir
discuter de ce genre de choses
aujourd'hui on prend pas du tout le
problème par le bon bout on ce parce que
la réalité on se met des oeillères en
disant voté pour moi et je vais
augmenter le pouvoir d'achat ouais enfin
si c'est physiquement possible
c'est pas du tout sûr que ça toi
alors peut-être que cette séquence a
éveillé pas mal de questions dans le
public donc si quelqu'un veut poser la
question des filles en une minute
oui
bonjour moi c'est pour revenir un peu
près aussi avec le sujet précédemment
donc j'entends l'injustice dont vous
avez parlé entre riches et pauvres
notamment mais on sait que 10 % de la
population donc des pulls des personnes
les plus aisées les plus riches dans le
monde contribue à la moitié des
émissions effectués est ce que ces
personnes là devraient pas être plus
mises à contribution que plus tôt touché
toute la société dans sa globalité et y
compris les personnes baa pauvres
n'ayant pas forcément des moyens
nécessaires à ces substituts dont on a
parlé
est-ce que vous avez conscience du fait
que vous en faites partie
des 10% les plus riches
à ses papattes anciennement c'est sûr
c'est totalement sur les gens qui sont
dans les gens qui font des études
supérieures d'ingénieurs sont
globalement des csp + et les csp + des
pays occidentaux font partie des 10% les
plus riches on vous en fait partie
absolument
moi aussi un voilà c'est une nouvelle
idée
là alors j'ai déjà cramé 30 secondes
pour vous répondre ça
une fois que je vous ai dit ça la
réponse à votre question elle demande un
plan c'est à dire que ça veut dire quoi
quand est-ce qu'on commence à être riche
quand est-ce qu'on commence à être
pauvres ça veut dire quoi une
restriction qu'est ce donc en fait il
faut compter faut distribuer faut
préciser et c'est donc en fait c'est
exactement l'esprit de ce qu'on a fait
là
c'est pas possible de répondre en une
minute à ce genre de question qui est
oui j'ai une mesure simple à vous
proposer qui correspond très exactement
à la façon dont on va distribuer les
forces
c'est une préoccupation qui doit rester
dans un plan d'ensemble
partout par rapport au transport
l'alimentation à l'accès au logement
alors partout
non les jets privés ça fait beaucoup
moins que l'aviation commerciale de
l'île mais par contre par vol ça fait
beaucoup plus oui ça c'est clair
que je le disais tout à l'heure une
manière de réguler le transport aérien
peut très bien être de donner un droit
de tirage à chaque français de quelques
vols en avion dans la des puits ça c'est
un système dans lequel vous n'avez pas
de limitation par l'argent
peut très bien faire ça
merci beaucoup pour votre réponse mais
ça répond à la question sur transport
aérien et pas du tout sur le bifteck
c'est pour ça je vous disais il faut une
réponse par questions posées
merci beaucoup du coup on va passer au
dernier sujet qui nous concerne
directement tous grands partis dans
cette salle est directement même si en
soit tous nous concerne c'est celui de
l'enseignement supérieur
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que depuis
plusieurs années les étudiants se
mobilisent au travers de toute la france
notamment au travers de mouvements
comme la coop deux étudiants de pardon
et
le manifeste de l'association pour un
réveil écologique qui ont récolté déjà
des dizaines de milliers de signatures
dans notre population va dire et qui
participe à un changement des formations
d'enseignement supérieur
de plus un grand nombre d'étudiants dans
notre génération
sont apeurés et inquiet quand ils voient
la tâche à accomplir et un terme qu'on
entend de plus en plus c'est le terme
des banques citées et voilà donc je vais
commencer ma première question des gens
je vous l ai d'autres ont participé à la
rédaction d'un rapport sur la formation
aux enjeux du changement climatique et
de la transition dans l'enseignement
supérieur commandé par le ministère lui
même
comment voyez-vous l'intégration des
enjeux de cette transition dans les
formations est-ce que selon vous toutes
les formations sont concernés et que
doit-on apprendre aux jeunes qui seront
les acteurs de cette même transition
toutes les formations doivent être
concernées oui parce que il faut
vérifier pour toutes les formations
qu'elles ont une compatibilité avec le
avec le monde chili il ya un travail qui
a été fait au chic project ces dernières
années avec un nom de code qui avec
climat ce
qui concerne précisément les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on a commencé
par les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur tout simplement parce qu'on
est une petite association aux chiffres
project et que
venant du monde du privé dans le monde
du privé en général on commence par
faire part monter la marche la plus
accessible de l'escalier
est le fruit qui pend le plus bas pour
prendre une traduction française une
expression anglais ce que vous
connaissez bien
pour nous c'était la question de
l'enseignement supérieur pourquoi parce
qu'on a affaire à des gens qui sont déjà
raisonnablement mature c'est beaucoup
plus facile de reparler de ce genre de
problème à quelqu'un qui à 22 ans que à
quelqu'un qui en a huit
la deuxième raison c'est que les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
en particulier les écoles ont une forme
d'autonomie dans la gestion de leurs
programmes qui leur permet d'être assez
réactive donc à partir du moment où il
ya une direction d'établissement qui a
vraiment envie de faire des choses les
choses bougent alors que dans le système
universitaire c'est plus lourd et au
niveau du secondaire s'est
considérablement plus lourd
donc ce qu'on a ce qu'on a fait c'est
qu'on a commencé par s'intéresser donc
aux questions d'établissement fin de
l'enseignement supérieur et au sein de
l'enseignement supérieur là où c'est
encore plus facile parce que directement
en rapport avec le problème à traiter
ces des écoles d'ingénieurs donc on a
commencé par les écoles d'ingénieurs
alors il ya un rapport qui est sorti un
premier rapport qui est sortie qui a été
fait en collaboration avec le haut pizza
qui a qui explique quel genre de méthode
il faut suivre si on veut mettre
l'enseignement en accord avec les
questions énergie et climat alors ça
veut pas juste dire faire par exemple
une fresque du climat en début de cursus
et puis m
3h02 d'exposer sur c'est quoi le pétrole
c'est quoi le charbon ça veut dire qu'il
ya tout un tas de cours dans lesquels il
faut faire rentrer cette problématique
ici vous êtes dans un établissement qui
s'intéresse à la manière de produire
puis de transformer puis de distribuer
ce qu'on mange vous voyez bien que vous
êtes heurter par cette problématique à
tous les étages on en a parlé ça
concerne ce qui se passe dans le champ
ça concerne ce qui se passe dans l'usiné
ça concerne ce qui se passe dans le
magasin ça concerne ce qui se passe chez
les gens ça concerne ceux qui ça
concerne des sujets de construction
européenne ça concerne des sujets de
géopolitique ça concerne des sujets ted
alimentaire savoirs extrêmement riche
qui fait signe le charme de vos études
et donc ça veut dire qu'on peut pas que
dire ah bon on va vous donner 10 heures
de cours au début puis après tout le
reste ça va rester de pareilles c'est on
peut parler si on veut mettre
l'enseignement que vous recevez en
harmonie avec les sujets qu'on évoque
aujourd'hui ça suppose de revisiter
toute l'ingénierie la formation ça
suppose de former une partie aux
enseignants éventuellement qu'ils ont
dans une partie où j'ai eu envie de voir
des vacataires ou leur dit parfois on
n'a plus besoin de toi dans ce genre là
où les gens qui partent à la retraite
[ __ ] on veut plus devoir est allé à ta
place on va prendre quelqu'un qui fait
quelque chose d'assez différent parce
que c'est ça qu'il faut que qu'il faut
qu'on fasse ça suppose éventuellement de
revisiter la manière dont se passent les
stages dans ce hall etc alors pour la
façon de rentrer dans toutes ces
questions qui est qu'ils vont amener des
réponses qui sont différentes en
fonction des établissements
c'est à dire que selon qu'on est à
l'école de la magistrature ou dans
l'école d'agronomie ici on va pas
répondre aux mêmes questions et apporter
les mêmes réponses
mais par contre le déroulé c'est à dire
la méthode le discours de la méthode on
a fait un travail donc avec le groupe i
de sa pour les écoles d'ingénieurs qui
est disponible qui est public il est
disponible sur le site du shit project
et on a commencé également à mettre des
ressources partagées en ligne par
exemple il ya ainsi que ça fait
l'enseigné le climat enseigner kiliba
point hors gains tout attaché qui a été
mis en ligne il n'y a pas très longtemps
il ya six mois et qui propose le partage
de ressources sur justement ces sujets
là et puis après les gens vont décliner
dans des contextes particuliers je fais
des visites pédagogiques sur chez pas
quoi dans tel endroit comment est ce que
je peux me prend
voilà donc la la la façon de donc
évidemment oui il faut il faut il faut
revoir la totalité de ce qui se passe
depuis votre entrée en formation jusqu'à
votre jusqu'à votre sortie et ça suppose
un travail collectif donc ça peut pas
être fait juste paru de personnes dans
son coin ça suppose l'assentiment du
corps enseignant et ça suppose
évidemment une impulsion forte de la
direction qui dit j'ai envie qu'on parte
dans ton pour la répétition du bon dans
cette direction là
merci beaucoup je vais maintenant de
donner la parole à solène qui est là une
question concernant les leviers
bonjour messieurs jancovici
2 quel levier disposons-nous futurs
ingénieurs des sciences du vivant pour
réaliser cette transition avez-vous des
coûts et à une donnée pour notre future
vie professionnelle
alors j'ai déjà des conseil à vous
donner pour votre actuel vis
d'étudiantes
utiliser ce moment
en tenant au sens études
enfin home aux études plus exactement
son sens le plus complet c'est-à-dire
profiter de ce moment où vous êtes un
peu à l'abri des vicissitudes de la vie
quotidienne ce qui va pas durer
pour emmagasiner le maximum de
compréhension du monde qui nous entoure
et le maximum d'informations qui vous
seront utiles plus tard parce que plus
tard vous serez placé dans des
situations dans lesquelles vous vous
améliorez dans le secteur dans lequel
vous serez mais vous aurez plus
tellement le temps d' élargir votre
champ de vision à d'autres domaines et
d'autres secteurs donc profiter de cette
période de vos études pour essayer
d'avoir un peu d'enrichir notre panorama
à 360° de comprendre comment la physique
se relier à l'économie comment les
différents pays peuvent évoluer
comment ça s'est passé au cours de
l'histoire comment etc enfin essayer
d'avoir une vision du système dans
lequel nous sommes c'est à ça que vous
serez c'est à ça que votre temps il sera
le plus utile et à côté de ça quelque
chose que vous pouvez également commencé
à faire parce que ça c'est pas
inintéressant non plus puis on a ainsi
pu accorder qu'on aime bien passer à
l'action de temps en temps c'est
éventuellement emparez-vous d'un projet
alors c'est n'importe quoi vous allez
enquiquiner votre directrice pour un
triplé nombre de places de vélo ici j'en
suis rien enfin n'importe quoi mais des
trucs un peu concret parce que c'est
très complémentaire c'est d'un côté il
ya je travaille du chapeau dans mon
fauteuil et puis de l'autre côté je met
les mains dans le cambouis et je fais un
truc un peu concrets qui suppose de
comprendre un peu ce que c'est qu'un
projet concret comment ça se traite et
c'est donc je vous conseille moi de
faire les deux et en fait la réponse à
la question vous m'avez posé je vais
bien gardés de la donner parce que je
vois pas au nom de quoi je vous la
donnerai c'est à vous de la trouver tout
seul et c'est à vous tous dans cette
salle de trouver ça tout seuls comme des
grands parce que de toute façon personne
va vous dicter ce qu'il vous plaît donc
à un moment vous ferez ce qui va vous
plaire et la seule chose que je peux moi
vous conseillez sait de quoi éclairer au
mieux le choix que vous ferez plus tard
et que vous ayez une vraie motivation
pour faire ce que vous allez faire voilà
c'est juste ça que je peux vous dire
merci au cou donc on va clôturer ce
thème par la question challenge 2
minutes
je propose de l'apprendre sur le live
s'il y a de quoi faire
ou alors nous avons peut-être une
question dans la salle louis
ce que vous avez dit au début du thème
sur le fait que farid fresque du climat
puis après ne plus en parler du tout
c'est complètement insuffisant moi ça
parle beaucoup c'est quelque chose que
j'ai beaucoup ressenti pendant mes
études par exemple on a eu un mois de
cours sur il va falloir réduire notre
production de viande et cetera et puis
un mois plus tard on nous expliquer
comment faire entrer un maximum de porcs
dans un bâtiment d'élevage j'ai trouvé
ça très compliqué à naviguer les deux
mais en même temps je suis arrivé à la
fin de ma formation d'ingénieur et je me
rends compte que si jamais je n'avais
pas eu toute cette formation-là sur le
monde agricole tel qu'il est
actuellement j'aurais eu beaucoup de mal
à comprendre les professionnels avec qui
il interagit et du coup comment former
les gens à comprendre le monde tel qu'il
est actuellement mais aussi comprendre
comment le changer je pense que c'est
pas antagonistes c'est à dire que le
monde tel qu'il est actuellement n'est
pas
ne relève pas ni d'une intention ni d'un
jugement de valeur ça relève d'une
description le monde tel qu'il doit
devenir lui il relève nécessairement
d'une intention et donc d'un jugement de
valeur parce que le jugement de valeur
nous conduit à dire parce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure par exemple restreindre
un peu de liberté individuelle pour
gagner en sécurité collective c'est une
affaire de valeurs c'est pas une affaire
de descriptions là pour le coup donc il
me semble ne sais pas du tout
antagonistes là où ça devient
antagonistes cécile enseignements que
vous avez reçu vous dit voilà comment on
fait pour faire entrer un maximum de
porcs dans un bâtiment d'élevage et à
l'avenir ça restera notre premier
critère alors même qu'on vous a dit
juste avant qu'il y avait un autre
critère qu'il fallait mettre dans
l'équation
c'est ça ou vous que là on recommence à
se marcher sur les pieds et donc ce que
je disais juste avant sur comment est ce
qu'on met une formation en adéquation
avec une problématique nouvelle c'est
justement que la personne qui vous a
fait cet enseignement elle accepte voir
un désir comprendre comment est-ce que
son enseignement peut concilier à la
fois la description de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et les marges de manoeuvre
et les contreparties parce que chaque
marge de manoeuvre avec une contrepartie
qui sont à notre disposition pour faire
autrement
et ça c'est typiquement de l'ingénierie
pédagogique c'est à dire que à un moment
on dit que le but du court c'est pas
juste de vous enseigner comment ça
marche aujourd'hui et comment perpétuer
le truc c'est comment ça marche
aujourd'hui et quelles sont les marges
de manoeuvre à disposition et leur
contrepartie parce qu'un prix à payer
tout le temps pour compenser autrement
donc avant de passer à une phase de
questions libres on a une dernière
question vous poser on sait que voulez
pas vous aider nous avait dit de la
conférence dédicace vous n'aviez pas
pensé quand vous avez tous mis de côté
la question du financement dans le film
project mais j'ai quand même vous poser
la question puisque elle est là la dca
même pas niant
la décarbonation de l'économie française
nécessite un large plan de transition ce
qui pose la question du financement des
candidats à gauche comme monsieur
mélenchon jadot ou russel propose de
faire à peu créé un impôt de solidarité
sur la fortune climatique parallèlement
d'autres candidats à droite propose de
baisser les impôts plus particulèrement
pour les riches qui serait alors motors
transition parallèlement certains
candidats suggère de faire peser ce clan
de transition sur les entreprises et
vous comment voyez-vous le financement
du plan de finances 2 comment voyez-vous
le plan du sien ce temps du projet qui
vous portez et sur le kid at il pesé
très honnêtement je pense que c'est
prématuré de répondre à votre question
parce qu'on a dit qu'aujourd'hui on
n'avait pas regardé ça
il ya des gens qui alors je vais vous
dire pourquoi par ailleurs l'économie
c'est vraiment un truc casse gueule je
vais commencer par vous donner un je
vais commencer par vous donner un
dans le domaine des énergies
renouvelables dont l'éolien et au
solaire il ya énormément de gens qui
disent pas c'est en train de devenir de
moins en moins chers donc vous voyez il
ya qu'à en faire de plus en plus et puis
on va régler le problème
question pourquoi est ce que les
holdings solaires sont en train de
devenir de moins en moins cher réponse
parce que c'est de plus en plus une
industrie mondialisée
boosté par les combustibles fossiles 95%
des panneaux sont faits en chine donc il
ya rien de plus mondialisé que le
panneau solaire
avec de la mine de la métallurgie de la
chimie etc tout ça ça fonctionne avec du
gaz du charbon et du pétrole est ce que
dans un monde dans lequel il n'y aurait
plus le pétrole pour les anges hanmin
plus le pétrole pour la chimie ah bon
plus le charbon pour la métallurgie plus
le pétrole pour le transport des
composants etc on aurait toujours des
anr pas cher réponse non ça serait
évidemment beaucoup plus cher
qu'aujourd'hui comment est-ce que le
raisonnement économique intègre ce que
je viens de vous dire la réponse il ne
le fait pas c'est à dire que il fait un
raisonnement par induction en disant je
garde c'est des trucs de collégiens
c'est descendu avant une règle et que je
prolonge aujourd'hui donc là alors je
vais vous donner maintenant un autre
exemple qui va dans le même sens
l'électricité renouvelable la moins
chère que nous ayons en france est ce
que vous savez laquelle s'est
dit oui absolument vous dites c'est pas
cher pisser renouvelables il ya qu'à en
faire plus où est le problème
le problème c'est qu'il faut des
montagnes qui sont gratuites mais qu'on
n'a pas donc c'est la moins chère et
pourtant c'est celle qu'on va avoir le
plus de problèmes à augmenter donc quand
on commence à prendre le problème sous
l'angle économique on peut faire de très
très grosses erreurs de jugement et donc
je suis très sincère quand je dis on n'a
pas souhaité parler d'argent au début et
donc du coup j'ai une limite dans la
réponse que je peux vous faire qui est
que c'est très difficile pour moi
aujourd'hui de vous parler d'argent en
disant bon je vais oublier ce que je
vous ai dit et maintenant je vais vous
alignez les centaines de milliards
j'ai une vraie réticence à faire ça un
jour c'est évident qu'il faudra qu'on
passe à cette époque-là cette étape lot
c'est à dire passer de la physique à la
convention humaine qu'il est pertinent
de mettre en place
mais est ce que je parle d'argent en
ayant obligé les entreprises par exemple
à internaliser le coût du co2 auquel cas
la formation des prix devient totalement
différente ou est-ce que je parle argent
avec le mécanisme actuel où la formation
des prix de tient pas compte des
ressources naturelles oui donc voilà
donc je je je
j'ai vraiment une vraie réticence à
passer tout de suite aux milliards en
dix ans je pense que c'est beaucoup plus
casse-gueule qu'autre chose de se
précipiter dans ce dans cette direction
là je pense qu'il faut aller jusqu'au
bout de l'exercice sur le plan physique
ce qu'on n'a pas encore fait et derrière
il faudra prendre
le temps qu'il faut
pour être capable de comprendre ce que
ça veut dire en termes de conventions
économiques qui permettent d'être
raccord avec cette direction là est
aujourd'hui utilisé la convention
économique du monde infini pour essayer
de traiter les problèmes du monde chili
si on garde pas une très très forte
hauteur de vue en permanence sur ce
qu'on est en train de faire on risque de
dire des grosses conneries ok très bien
merci
on va pouvoir passer
à une phase questions libres je pense
qu'on peut commencer par une question du
bouclage
alors on a une question au niveau du
thème social plutôt dans un monde en
transition quels indicateurs de
développement de nos sociétés utiliser
si ce n'est plus la croissance du pib
il ya une analogie que j'aime bien
qui vaut ce qu'elle vaut parce qu'elle
est issue du monde mécanisé qui est
celle du tableau de bord quand vous
voulez savoir si votre voiture va bien
vous vérifiez qu'il ya suffisamment
d'essence dans le réservoir ou
suffisamment d'électricité dans la
patrie que la température du moteur va
bien que la pression des pneus bien que
vous n'êtes pas en train de rouler au
delà de la vitesse autorisée et c'est
donc en fait vous avez un certain nombre
d'indicateurs et chacun d'entre eux est
important alors si je voulais prendre
untel plus médical ça peut-être plus
sympathique et points - en désaccord
avec le sco julien degen
si vous voulez regarder si un patient va
bien vous regardez sa température
regarder sa pression vous regardez un
certain nombre de constantes
physiologique et vous dit pas il y en a
juste une qui me donne toute l'histoire
est bien là c'est exactement pareil
c'est à dire que le pilotage de notre
société vers une organisation qui soit
respectueuse des limites planétaires qui
cherche pas à les déplacer va demander
de surveiller un indicateur par les
beats qui nous intéresse il n'y aura pas
un indicateur unique et d'enlever le pib
aujourd'hui on l'a trop hâtivement
assimilé à tous c'est à dire que la
croissance du pib s'était plus de
travail plus de bien-être plus de ceux
ci plus de cela à leur premier ordre ce
n'est pas complètement faux dans un
monde infini parce que ça veut dire plus
d'objets sans avoir de contrepartie
environnementale désagréable plus
d'emplois sans avoir de contrepartie
désagréable sur la nature de l'emploi
plus de ceci et c mais aujourd'hui on
peut plus raisonner comme ça parce que
enfin vous connaissez tous cette blague
à plus d'obèses et plus d'accidents de
la route ça fait plus de pib donc
est ce que c'est vraiment une bonne idée
et donc il va probablement falloir en
revenir à un système dans lequel on a
des indicateurs plus explicite qui nous
intéresse alors ces indicateurs
explicite il y en a un que moi j'aime
bien parce qu'il est juste impossible à
mesurer mais je tiens c'est la fraction
des gens qui sont contents c'est un
indicateur important
mais on ne mesure pas en tant que tel
alors le bhoutan le mesure paraît-il
avec son bonheur national brut on peut
mesurer tout un tas d'autres indicateurs
sociétaux
les sujets d'éducation les sujets de
l'adéquation entre le métier que vous
faites est celui que vous auriez aimé
faire sur plein de trucs qu'on peut
qu'on peut mesurer la quantité d'air pur
laquelle vous avez accès par an mais
aujourd'hui vous avez non mais enfin
voilà
il ya un tableau de bord qui reste à
inventer aujourd'hui dans ce qui est
fait y'a rien qui soit totalement
satisfaisant je trouve
et le pib on peut continuer à le mesurer
cette vous amuse il faut juste pas
raccrocher toutes les politiques
publiques à ce cas
merci est ce qu'il y aurait d'autres
questions dans la salle où elle en a
plein
je remarque
que la proportion of fame des gens qui
posent des questions et inverse à la
proportion hommes femmes dans cet
établissement
j'ai dit ça j'ai rien dire
bonjour bon bah je tombe mal mais la
prochaine j'espère que ce sera vous
je voulais revenir sur la thématique 5
donc sociale un peu plus vous allez
parler de personnes âgées donc quelle
est la place des personnes âgées dans la
transition est en lien donc notamment
avec les présidentielles
qu'est ce qu'on fait de la retraite dans
le monde futur que vous imaginez
en garde aurel on en fait probablement
moins de retraite malheureusement la
retraite quand vous regardez
historiquement comment elle est apparue
elle est apparue quand la société est
devenue suffisamment productive pour
qu'on ait les moyens de fournir de quoi
vivre à des gens qui ne participent pas
directement
à la fourniture de la production alors
en fait ça ça demande quelque chose de
très précis pour arriver c'est des
machines à partir du moment où c'est les
machines qui produisent les machines
produits suffisamment pour les gens qui
sont dus au travail et les gens qui sont
10 à la retraite sachant que
physiquement quand vous regardez ce que
les gens font de leur journée une bonne
partie des gens qui sont à la retraite
ont des trucs ils font des trucs dans la
journée qu'ils ressentent très
exactement à ce que font des gens au
travail ils discutent ils sont assis ils
sont derrière un ordinateur ils se
déplacent
truc qui ressemble très exactement à ce
que font des gens qui sont qui sont au
travail il ya plus tellement de
différences physiques pour un certain
nombre d'activités
là
mon père qui était enseignant quand il
était en activité il passait son temps à
faire des petits calculs de la fac comme
lidl et des enfants puis il passait son
temps à parler à des gens ça ça préfère
des cours et quand il était à la
retraite et ben il passait son temps
faire des petits calculs chez lui et il
passait son temps à parler à des gens
donc en fait la retraite aujourd'hui
c'est formellement permis par le fait
que la société d'abondance permet de
nourrir des inactifs c'est également
vrai pour les études longues donc quand
vous regardez ce qui se passait à
l'époque où l'énergie et est peu
abondante et donc il y avait peu de
machines pour nous aider il n'y avait
pas d'études longues pour dédier à deux
siècles y avait pas d'études longues
y'avait pas de retraite il y avait des
semaines plus chargé y'avait pas de
congés payés tout ça est arrivé avec
avec l'énergie abondante donc on peut
raisonnablement imaginer que dans un
monde beaucoup plus contraints en
énergie
vraisemblablement qu'une partie de ce
que je viens de décrire va fortement se
modifier
merci d'autres questions
il y en a partout
bonjour j'aimerais savoir comment
peut-on innover sans engendrer de choc
énergétique
alors comment peut-on innover sans en
moins c'est-à-dire
dans une de vos conférences vous avez
donné des exemples de plusieurs
innovations qui avait été faite quand on
était passé du pas par exemple autres
acteurs dans l'agriculture
mais ça peut être toutes sortes
d'innovations et que on avait commencé à
consommer beaucoup plus donc est ce que
ce serait possible d'innover sans
engendrer de choc énergétique oui bien
sûr alors prenons toujours un exemple
dans l'agriculture
toutes les routes les amap c'est des
innovations pas nécessairement des
innovations techniques serre que je sais
pas si votre question sur l'innovation
était limitée à la technique où ça
pouvait aussi être des innovations
organisationnelles
ce serait et emma par exemple comme on
sera deux futurs ingénieurs on va devoir
on est tout le temps dans l'innovation
et c est ce qu'on pourra créer des
choses enfin tout en étant dans la
transition énergétique
attendant seulement vous pouvez mais
vous allez devoir oui
chez moi je vais prendre un exemple
idiot à très très trial l'irrigation au
goutte à goutte
c'est une innovation technique et c'est
tout à fait compatible avec une
évolution vers la sobriété
dans l'est en europe on va avoir un
problème d'accès à l'eau qui est déjà
alors pour voir va pas avoir d on va pas
devenir le sahara mais je veux dire on
va avoir un climat qui va
progressivement des salles qui vont
progressivement s'assécher ça va
demander de la créativité pour s'adapter
à ce genre de situation il va y avoir
des parties techniques il va y avoir des
parties qui seront plus sociétale
d'alors
faisait la suggestion en disant
peut-être que le maïs dans le sud ouest
on peut le remplacer par autre chose
qu'on mangera et l'eau directement
plutôt que de le donner à des cochons il
ya de la volaille regardez donc la la la
question de l'innovation elle est pas du
tout rendu impossible par le fait qu' on
va devoir aller vers un monde qui sera
plus sobre en énergie a pas deux il ya
pas deux il n'y a pas de l'antagonisme
entre les deux par contre ce qui va se
passer c'est que ça ne permettra pas
nécessairement les mêmes innovation donc
dans un monde dans lequel il ya
l'abondance énergétique vous pouvez
innover pour faire un grand suppositoire
qui s'appelle la fusée blue origin est
ensuite envoyé en l'air j'ai pu troquer
le milliardaire qui sont vers dès qu'ils
en avaient marre de jouer aux cartes bon
ce genre d'innovation effectivement
c'est pas une innovation qui va dans le
sens de quelque chose qui est
une contraction de l'approvisionnement
énergétique par contre une innovation
sur comment est ce que j'utilise moins
de tracteurs pour travailler mais sol
ben ça c'est quelque chose qui est
parfaitement compatible avec la sobriété
par exemple et que les techniques de
semis sans labour sont des techniques
qui permettent de diminuer la puissance
des engins qu'on a parce que en fait ce
qu'ils consomment surtout de la
puissance et du gasoil c'est le travail
du sol en profondeur
et c'est tout à fait une innovation
technique qui perd qui est conciliable
avec
le une contrainte qui est qu'il faut
utiliser moins de combustibles fossiles
dans l'agriculture donc oui il y aura
plein de place pour de l'innovation ça
renvoie un peu à la question qui a été
posée tout à l'heure sur les
antagonismes dans l'étude il faut se
donner le bon cahier des charges voilà
mais non seulement il y aura de la place
mais je pense que il y aura besoin
je pense qu'on peut avant une dernière
question
on va falloir choisir
bonjour moi je vous dis juste posé une
question concernant l'approvisionnement
des centrales nucléaires en uranium est
ce qu'on peut vraiment dire qu'on est
indépendant
dans la production électrique en france
où on a des questions à se poser non on
est dépendant surtout comme je le disais
tout à l'heure il n'y a pas une mine
métallique en france l'uranium est un
métal donc on est parfaitement
dépendants de l'étranger pour
s'approvisionner en uranium
la question de la dépendance en fait
elle ne peut être vu que comme une
question relative c'est si on veut être
totalement indépendant on ne fait plus
rien mais par ailleurs on ne fait plus
d'éoliennes non plus puisqu'on n'a pas
une mine de fer en france et on n'a pas
une mine de charbon métallurgique en
regard d'un mât d'éolienne qui est en
acier donc le si on rêve de
l'indépendance en fait ça n'existe pas
la bonne question c'est comment est-ce
qu'on gère notre dépendance et ça il ya
deux règles qu'il faut utiliser la
première c'est essayer d'avoir sur son
sol suffisamment de stock pour avoir
suffisamment longueur de vue pour être
capable de se retourner en cas de
problème et ça l'uranium offre cette
possibilité parce que c'est très facile
de stocker sur le sol français quelques
années d'utilisation de l'uranium et
donc si vous avez un fournisseur qui
voulait aussi on à poutine qui nous font
du radium en quelques années on peut se
retourner
en trois endroits non mais en quelques
années on fera tourner et la deuxième
manière de gérer cette dépendance est
d'essayer de dépendre de gens qui ont
symétriquement besoin de vous
la bonne dépendance et d'interdépendance
et la dépendance mutuelle c'est la
symbiose quelque part c'est l'arbre de
champignons donc
si vous êtes le champignon il faut
trouver un arbre et inversement est bien
en ce qui concerne les métaux il faut
essayer idéalement
d'être dépendant au maximum de pays qui
à un moment ou un autre ont besoin de
nous et envie d'avoir besoin de nous
c'est un peu c'est un peu ça le sujet
voilà donc c'est des questions d'
horizons de temps cédé question de
quantité et c'est des questions
d'interlocuteurs mais juste pour ajouter
enfin en français areva qui s'occupe de
l'approvisionnement d'une chaire surtout
principalement au niger j'imagine mais
est ce qu'on peut se regarder un peu
dans la glace en regardant la position
dans la situation politique qui se passe
au mieux et de se dire là on a une
interdépendance mais est ce qu'elle est
vraiment bénéfique pour le pays outre on
aura nos explique exploite pardon
effectivement une mine d'uranium au
niger mais c'est assez la partie amont
de l'activité d'orane hausse est plus
arrivé maintenant il faut savoir que les
opérateurs miniers et les opérateurs
pétroliers en fait ils ont des activités
amont et aval qui ne communiquent pas
entre eux alors je vais vous donner un
exemple avec le pétrole les raffineries
de total qui sont situés en france ne
raffine pas du pétrole qui est produit
par total total produit son pétrole dans
les pays où total à des puits
en
nigeria en russie je prends au bref
gabon
en iran et à ce moment totalement sur le
marché mondial le pétrole produit par
ces puits est par ailleurs les
raffineries de total situés en france
achète le pétrole sur le marché mondial
donc entre les deux géants billerach
rappelle le marché mondial c'est
exactement pareil en ce qui concerne les
métaux je vais vous prendre un autre
exemple que je connais bien qui est à m
eramet produits du nickel et bien le
nickel qui est utilisé en france dans
les raffineries des rats m c'est pour
partie du nickel qui est pas produit par
eramet et inversement le dit qu'elle
produit par des rames est en nouvelle
calédonie par sur le marché mondial vous
avez un
donc on aura nos effectivement exploite
une mine d'uranium et digère je ne sais
pas si c'est cet uranium là qui rentre
dans les usines d'enrichissement ou pas
par ailleurs ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'en termes de réserve mondiale les
premiers pays détenteur de réserves sont
le canada l'australie la russie et le
kazakhstan donc on trouve quand même la
lie poutine dans la sphère avant le
digère après il ya un autre sujet qui
est un truc qui n'a rien à voir avec la
dépendance qui est est ce que oui ou non
il ya des choses à dire sur les
conditions sociales d'exploitation d'une
mine ici et là alors ça c'est un autre
débat et il est mené en tant que tel
alors si la question est est-ce qu'on en
n'utilisant pas de nucléaire on va
échapper à ce débat la réponse est non
parce que si vous utilisez pas de
nucléaire vous avez le même débat sur
est-ce que le graphite qui est produit
pour faire des batteries il est produit
dans des usines douce et sociales ou pas
sociale est ce que le cuivre qui est
produit dans les mines chiliennes il est
social ou pas sociale et vous avez
besoin de beaucoup plus de cuivre si
vous lui commencé à mettre des panneaux
et des éoliennes partout que si vous
avez du nucléaire bref c'est un débat
auquel vous avez droit quel que soit
j'ai envie de dire l'option que vous
prenez il n'y a pas un cas de figure
dans lequel vous vous prenez sur la
figure et d'autres vous dites j'ai déjà
complètement
merci alors les deux personnes de
voulaient me font des très grands gestes
donc je pense qu'ils ont une super
questions à nous poser
super on vous laissera en juger mais
pour finir nous avons reçu une question
un peu littéraire sur laquelle on
aimerait vous entendre disserter un
petit peu
avec la métaphore de l' incendie qui
arrivera et réveillera les esprits ne
peut-on pas déclenché volontairement 7
incendies avant que l'affairé ne soit
trop sèche est ce que le pompier doit
être un peu pyromane histoire quand lui
ont conclus augmente le nombre de lances
à incendie le camion
s'est un peu joué à l'apprenti sorcier
ce genre de chose quand on commence a
déclenché un incendie dans la forêt pour
ready envoyé on a besoin de moyens de
lutte contre l'incendié faut être sûr
que l' incendie va pas s'étendre trop
loin trop vite
c'est pas un jour de grand mistral et de
grande sécheresse et
personnellement je suis pas très fan à
de ce genre de solution
ça vous en particulier le pompier
pyromane dans le jugement social on
considère rarement que il a eu raison
d'être pyroban
donc les gens qui s'agitent pour essayer
de proposer des solutions je renvoie un
peu ce que je disais tout à l'heure sur
la taxe carbone et l'augmentation des
prix quand c'est le marché qui décide
le fait est que
on est un peu condamnés quand même à
attendre que la baffe viennent de
l'extérieur plutôt que de la donne et
nous mêmes parce qu'il ya une question
de légitimité derrière à intervenir dans
le débat si c'est donc il a abandonné
donc il semble que la question
c'est pas un échappatoire je pense
vraiment que la question se pose pas
vraiment et que ça serait au fond
fortement s'affaiblir que au motif qu'
on a la solution de dire attendez je
vais vous déstabiliser un peu comme ça
vous verrez bien que la solution est la
bonne je pense que c'est malheureusement
pas très acceptable dans l'esprit d'une
large partie de la population
merci beaucoup avant de passer à la
conclusion j'aimerais savoir s'il y
avait un sujet qu'on n'a pas évoqué que
vous aimeriez
on parle et
j'ai pas votre place donc sûrement plein
de sujets qu'on a évoqué mais qu'on n'a
pas évoqué
quelque chose ou si non plus simplement
de poser une question autres
moi j'ai une question pour vous j'ai le
droit oui vous avez un sondage à main
levée
j'aimerais bien savoir dans l'assistance
la
les sujets qu'on évoque qui allait la
fraction d'entre vous à qui ça donne
envie de vous battre et qui est la
fraction d'entre vous à qui ça vous
donne envie surtout plus en entendre
parler
alors à qui cette donne envie de se
battre
qui a envie de pleurer
or quelques heures m
ça peut être les mêmes non mais par
ailleurs la norme sociale fait que ceux
qui disent qu'ils ont envie de se battre
ils vont lever le bras tout de suite et
les autres on va pas les voir donc à mon
avis il ya un petit côté secret de
l'isoloir qui est nécessaire pour sonder
vraiment les choeurs sur ce genre de